Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
just checking in on you.
You cubicle dwell in cons.
Um,
you know something.
I'd feel bad for you if you're sitting in a cubicle right now,
but I'm just so full of myself that I just don't have time to have empathy.
I'm just going to sit here and a big hot tub of my own white privilege.
And speaking of other white males.
Yes.
Why would you have another white male on your podcast?
You know why?
Because I'm not woke.
Um,
th 200% wrong today,
Bill.
200% wrong.
That's right.
Just when you thought the percentage couldn't go any higher.
I have the wonderful,
they always classy.
One of the few gentlemen my wife loves you.
Like she'd get like that one night we all hung up.
Sorry.
Let me it Nate,
Craig and Nate is here.
Not because he loves me,
not because he actually tried to pass the puck to me in the slot and I still
shot it right into the goalies fucking glove.
Remember that fucker went around like defense man,
he's here because he has a new album comedy album that's available on iTunes and
Amazon and all over the Internet called preferred customers.
Uh,
one of my favorite people,
one of my favorite comics,
Nate Craig,
welcome bill.
Thanks for having,
first of all I want to say I love,
we all love Nia as well and a man,
the gentlemen introduction.
I'll take it run and buddy.
Thank you.
We talking about,
yeah,
the amount of times that you've sent flowers.
You've sent cards because you know we had a kid and all of that shit.
You're,
you're,
you're a class act.
You're a Midwest guy.
What does it feel to be living out here in Hollywood and just referred to as a,
do they treat you like a flyover comic?
Ah,
yeah.
Some one.
The response
there is fine.
This is that I get from,
uh,
from being from the Midwest.
There are pretty hilarious.
People just don't,
they think you're a Trump supporter who just say Wisconsin and people laugh
in your face.
Now.
Do you think that's cause the badgers lost three fucking rose bowls on a rough.
Well that's got something to do with it.
Yeah.
How could it not?
You gotta you gotta they gotta do something.
Math whiskey like bat way.
If you had to bet money who's taken the next title?
And it's hard with a college cause everybody fucking leaves but basket you got a
better chance in basketball or football.
It's Wisconsin.
Wisconsin meant we're not leaving that state.
You'd fucking cheesy.
Eaton motherfucker football for sure.
Football.
Yeah.
I don't know if I'm not,
your passport team was all right.
They weren't so they lost their hall of fame head coach.
Um,
because uh,
yeah,
because what happened?
What happened?
Cause outside fees is side piece went public.
Oh yeah.
Why does that get you fired?
Uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I think it was really a [inaudible] your wife just fire you and take your
fucking house.
You can't be a basketball coach.
And then where does he go from there?
Like some,
like some fucking a,
you know,
community college,
like a Delta risk behaviors.
Okay.
Oh Man.
I think he was ready to retire.
Obviously he wanted him to get his guy the job.
So he got his,
the job,
he was like a serial killer that wanted to get caught,
fucking banged or right down there to Hooters.
I want to bring it back to one of the America that I remembered where your side
piece didn't make you lose your job.
It was,
it was handled in house.
You white fucking slapped you.
She took you for everything that you had and then you just slowly drank herself
to death.
But it was none of my business.
Like why should I know that that guy was banging his Wa Bank fucking around on
his wife.
Yeah.
I didn't need to know any of that.
And uh,
definitely not a few.
It's going to keep going to final fours.
Yeah.
Just out of curiosity,
do you think if you have a side piece,
you no longer can explain the triangle offense to a incoming freshmen?
Like what does that have so many successful people,
they are college kids.
You gotta be real focused,
but some listen,
so many successful fucking people.
The reason why this is successful is because they have laser focus on their
career,
but everything else in their life is a mess.
Their personal life's a mess.
You sit down to talk to him,
they got a million things on their fucking mind.
So,
because this guy basically doesn't have a perfect life,
Nate Kraig can no longer get excited about the fucking final four.
Thank you.
Over a side piece.
I can't say it out loud,
but I'm glad you did bill.
I mean,
I don't know.
I,
uh,
I just don't like knowing that shit.
I don't,
I,
I honestly,
that's none of my fucking business.
And I think I actually thinks it brings more pain to his wife now.
Um,
no,
I just,
it's just,
it's none of my fucking business.
Yeah.
And I don't expect anybody that they're going to be perfect,
but if you get in a fucking team to the final four,
okay.
And you're not banging kids in the shower like they were doing at Penn state.
I mean,
that I get,
you're not be,
didn't beat up his wife.
This isn't what you wanted to talk about.
I mean,
I'm just saying he fucked around.
I loved them.
Bo Ryan,
Paul Ryan,
Hall of fame.
Bobo had a little Ho Ho on the side.
Huh?
And that was the best thing that ever happened in Wisconsin basketball.
And uh,
you know what,
um,
if you had to build a defense for both,
how would I know I would do it.
I say like,
listen,
your honor,
I,
I'd make sure I had a male judge and it'd be like,
you know,
we don't get to choose the Jasper.
This is Wisconsin.
There's a fly over state.
You know,
you guys came in,
read out there,
you guys can't even fucking read out there fucking cheese.
I'm sure you in Wisconsin going to go to pick your judge.
I'm going to pick a judge.
Just let me live this far.
Do you meet your judges
and Hazard County?
So I pick a fucking,
that's a dukes of hazard,
uh,
reference for you younger people.
So I picked a male judge,
right?
And I would just be like,
look,
your honor,
can I approach the bench is too many brides and hey,
I don't want them to hear this,
right.
This is my fantasy court.
So he come walking up and say,
listen,
you're a successful guy.
Right?
Okay.
Now hasn't your wife always made sure that you fucking,
you know,
she always knocked shut down a little bit,
just so you feel like you don't get too big for your Britches,
no matter what you achieve.
She's always kind of just knocking you down a little bit just to make sure,
you know,
judge nobody knows better than you.
Uh,
the effort,
these Yak,
that successes,
I wasn't going that route.
I was going the route that she's just fucking,
you know,
she's still running the shit.
Like the more successful you get,
the more they're going to knock you down.
So there's still running shit around the house.
So then what happens is,
is you don't feel he does,
it's,
he bows over their case.
Guys go on to the final four,
like three fucking years in a row.
Okay?
I don't need to tell you that you're living in this state that you going to,
you got to fucking Badger Pin.
Right and you'll roll.
Okay.
Probably shouldn't have worried that during the trial might get a mistrial,
but this guy,
he's,
I am a big badger fan.
Bill.
You make a good point.
The Guy,
he needs a blow job every once in a while and it makes them relax.
It makes him here as team.
Okay.
We're so close right now.
We are so close to getting a fucking title.
Okay.
You're saying this is for the kids.
It's for the kids.
It's a fucking Cyprus.
Okay.
This is,
this is between him and his wife.
That's all I'm saying.
All right.
Let them settle it.
Okay.
It then say it.
I'm not saying she shouldn't take the house and everything he's got and go fuck
one of his friends.
I'm not saying that,
I'm just saying we are so close to a fucking championship and I,
I think I speak for the state of Wisconsin when I say you let this man keep
coaching at your university.
They have been playing good defense lately.
They have been playing down daddy fence,
lockdown defense.
Come on.
It'd be nice.
In a perfect world,
you could,
you could pick your judges and your side piece.
Litigation.
Yeah.
No,
this is just,
yeah,
it's a,
uh,
it's,
Joe Rogan says this strange times.
It is strange.
It's a strange time.
Strange Times.
What does being a,
I saw two people on the Internet talking about how they're sick of being asked
about this thing that they were both talking to each other about on Twitter.
I just want him to tweet.
Did you two ever consider exchanging cell phone numbers?
What are you doing anyways?
You're a big baseball fan.
I'm a moderate,
moderate baseball fan.
Yeah.
I remember when that the brewers won the first game and you texted me.
He said,
you said Bill,
ladies and gentlemen,
your Milwaukee brewers.
They brought,
they brought the fucking lumber out.
That game.
I was going to happen.
I thought they were going to make it to the series.
I thought I was going to,
that we're going to have a little Boston,
Milwaukee.
If you could see the way nature down rubbing his fucking face.
Right.
And I just think that his aims are soft.
They're just soft.
I'm not,
there's no,
there's only a couple of guys on that team I'm scared of.
I'm pissed that we couldn't beat him.
Like it's gotta be well sin,
no guy with a red face.
It's Justin Turner.
Manny Machado's get the best fucking and that should be,
it should have been Ballenger and then the ace to start her.
And I also like,
by way I don't,
as I was saying you,
I don't think Manny Machado was dirty.
Okay.
Ty Cobb did all of that shit and he's all over the fucking hall of fame.
Right.
Because there wasn't slow mo high def replay to show you when he kicked of,
I thought because it was white on white crime back then because it wasn't all
white league that it was okay if,
if ty Cobb,
uh,
you know,
spiked to Ulysses,
whoever the fuck was playing second base back then,
right.
Aberdeen,
whatever the hell his fucking name was.
Right.
I don't think ty Cobb discriminated.
Oh,
that's what I've heard.
You know what it was is probably a white guy who had the audacity to have a
little bit of a Tan that is really fucking weird about like,
you know you,
there's like straight up racist in the hall of fame.
Do you know there was,
there was a fucking guy,
and I don't know if this is true or not,
if this is just some scuttlebutt,
but there's literally like a guy in the hall of fame who used to carry a piece
from a rope from a lynching is good luck.
Can that be true?
Ooh,
that's a tough one.
That is worse than a side.
Pete and Pete rose can't get into the hall of fame because he bet on the fucking
dogs.
It comes to the chief.
I liked this,
the scuttle butt potential Scuttlebutt disclaimer,
all because everything,
cause all I do,
the only research I do is I talk to somebody in a bar or I search it on the
Internet and I click on the first thing and whatever it says like I was making,
you know,
sort of in a way,
like a,
what was it?
Kate Upton,
she was chime in and on the Houston red sox series.
So I'm sitting there going,
oh,
according to Kate Upton,
which was funny to me.
And then I was like,
wow,
isn't that cool?
She's that beautiful and she's done into baseball and so many fine brothers,
hey fuck head.
She's married to Justin Verlander.
She's carrying his kid right now.
It's like,
now it makes sense now.
It makes sense.
Okay,
got it.
But why does it need to make sense to me?
Yeah.
Why?
Why am I mansplaining?
Yeah.
The only thing on my own plot can only thing wrong with that was the research.
Yeah,
it was the discovery.
Well,
I feel like I'm a victim of like the intellect that I was blessed with.
So I'm the victim.
I can't help it if people are going to lie and then I'm going to read or maybe
they tell the truth and I don't read it.
And I think somewhere in there,
in this current climate,
I could somehow become a victim there.
It's the only true victim hood is not taking responsibility for your own fucking
actions,
correct?
Yes.
Yeah.
Just uh,
just being expected to research what it is you're having an opinion on.
I have a Wisconsin question for you.
You grew up there,
right?
Madison,
Wisconsin,
smack Dab,
and you could not escape Wisconsin if you want it to.
Like if you were walking on foot,
how long would it take you to get to a great lake or Minnesota?
Couple of days.
It would take me a full,
it would take me,
yeah,
I'd say one,
one 24 hour period.
One 24 hour period.
All right.
In the summer of course.
Um,
okay,
so I want to know here in the winter,
I want to know how you got out of there,
out of the great state of Wisconsin without becoming a serial killer,
because that is kind of on the low that if you guys weren't so good at making
cheese right then he didn't have the packers.
Yeah,
there'd be a lot.
If you remove those two.
No,
no knives in,
it'd be more,
I'm just saying like that really would be,
you'd have to steer into that and that would have to be your calling card to
basically visit all of these people's houses.
He had Jeffrey Dahmer.
You had the fucking,
the guy who basically they've made like nine different serial killer movies just
based off of everything that he did.
They couldn't fit it all into one script.
Talking about Ed [inaudible],
ed [inaudible],
ed gain.
He was Hannibal Lecter.
He was the Texas chainsaw massacre guys too.
Maybe.
I Dunno what Texas might get mad at that.
Hey,
don't be taken our fucking serial killers there.
Yeah.
Liberal fucking snowflake.
Fucking and scooter drive and freckled.
I'm the only guy I know.
Defense,
serial killers.
I'm the only guy I know
ever been asked.
Remember that we were on the road and we just thought that was the funniest
thing ever.
So redneck shit talking.
I'll start with that.
Yep.
I'm the only one word.
Caver I think I heard some guy on the,
on the plane or something.
Say it.
It's just such a ridiculous way to,
to brag about yourself.
I'm the only guy I ever know.
I'm only guy I know I have.
No,
I'm the only guy I've ever met.
I'm only guy I ever met with a pan bathrobe.
Yeah,
Dude.
We did that for hours.
Where will we drive was at that time we did that Gig in Winnipeg and we drove
all the way up to fucking Sasquatch.
Ooh.
That was a different time I think,
but we still had a southern accent on that for some reason.
I don't know why we didn't go Canadian.
It's just so fun to do the southern accent.
Oh,
you do with the good Canadian this so sorry.
sorry.
Oh,
oh,
sorry.
I said,
oh,
we're going up to Saskatoon.
We,
that was a fun drive that was so flat.
That's the flattest earth I've ever seen in my life.
Yeah,
well that's what they farm out that way.
And I mean dude,
it was so flat that you could see the earth rounding down now and you could
actually see the northern lights disappear over the flat horizon up there man.
Well that
they farmed there as,
as I read Bonnie Mcfarlane's book and her dad for some reason went to like
Alberta,
which is all rocky and you want to either have like cattle or drill for oil and
for whatever reason he was like,
fuck this,
I'm going to try to farm here.
And just made their life,
I guess a much more difficult than it needed to be,
which is why she's now a comedian.
I imagine that was your line in Winnipeg.
It was just cause flying into that city.
I mean it's just nothing with Oh yeah.
Nothing around it.
And you were like,
I've never felt so safe landing kind of landed anyway.
You were a lot of options.
Shut your eyes and just auto rotate to you,
felt your skids,
touch the ground.
It's going to be level still running,
landing.
Um,
so anyways,
let's talk about your album.
Where,
uh,
where did you tape this soon to be deemed a masterpiece.
Oh,
the masterpiece happened at dynasty typewriter.
It's a new spot.
It's at the,
the,
hey,
we're,
I'm the only guy I ever met recorded an album of the dynasty tap rider couldn't
tap.
We'll say Sandler did it.
Uh,
his part of his special there,
his new,
a special,
oh,
I got to see that.
That just came out on the 23rd.
It's great.
There's some of some of that is shot there.
Um,
but I am,
I am the only guy I ever met did album at the dynasty typewriter.
And you made a say day.
Uh,
yeah.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
No I didn't.
I mean it's a,
it's a great place.
I'm putting my next one out on laser disk,
laser disk.
I just want the true fans to fucking get it.
Is My phone on making all that noise.
Um,
oh,
what did I do now?
Oh,
my headphones.
We're working perfect.
And then I had the audacity to touch something.
Can you still hear me Nate?
Cause I can't hear myself.
I can hear yourself loud and clear.
Okay.
Oh wait a second.
Does this going to come through?
Oh,
guess who just got tick?
It's where are you going to go see bill?
That's per,
I'm going to go to the fucking red sox.
I had a boy go support your team.
Go to game.
Three or four cause there ain't gonna be no game.
Five buddy.
Oh,
would you look at that?
Okay.
Oh my God.
That's awesome.
That is awesome.
Oh k bellies in the game.
You're gonna sit in the bleachers.
I'm sitting up top with the real people and even be down.
Swing me downstairs talking to Jane Fonda.
Jane,
honestly,
how many games did you watch this year?
Hanging out with Paula Abdul and in the dugout club here were cold hearted
snake.
Is that what she's saying?
I had the biggest fucking crush on her.
There were so many fucking hot chicks and the late fucking eight,
uh,
there was a chick,
what was her name?
Can't remember any of them.
Samantha Fox.
Okay.
Fucking,
uh,
the one you just said,
Paula Abdul
who was the one and I'm a cadre from labyrinth and she was in requiem for a
dream.
The,
she's got brown hair.
Got and going to weaver.
No,
no,
not Sigourney weaver,
but that was Tyler.
Okay.
Jane Fonda.
I'll think about it.
Yeah.
Paula Abdul met her at the dugout club.
You dead still good looking,
right?
Yeah,
she's Paula Abdul.
She's great.
Didn't not visible,
but you guys are judge her work and not the way she looks.
Opposites attract.
Uh Huh.
Could you stop being a track to get the cars up?
Oh yes.
Attract.
That's right.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
but you take two steps back.
You know when you know when the album was over,
when does that,
that's what we should be talking about was was the stupid video she made with
the cat and they had the animated cat which was supposed to be like,
uh,
that's when I was being like,
all right.
I think they're trying to get too many hits off this album.
That was opposites attract.
I think that was the video for that.
Oh was it?
I think so.
So easy to write a fucking hit song back then,
right?
Bump,
bump,
bump wardrobe.
Bob Bobo.
Bobo.
I don't think it's going any harder.
It's more comfortable.
Bodo boat boat,
boat.
Obu back to my album bell.
Yeah.
Dynasty type.
I can cracked bumper of of God an album on the enter.
Nahin
Tammy,
Nate,
how did you come up?
Sorry.
I feel like I'm driving across country with you right now.
You're just giddy cause you got tickets to the world series.
I'm also guilty cause I had that operation men over 50 have and I find out I'm
not going to fucking die ass cancer.
I fucking did that yesterday.
What did you get put in your butt hole?
I had,
I,
as I kept saying to Nia,
she,
I go two days down,
I go,
Jacques Cousteau up the ass.
Ho.
It's what I kept calling it.
I had you get a colonoscopy.
Yeah.
So it's,
it's just a procedure.
It's a procedure.
They just sneak that camera up in.
Yeah.
It's the easiest thing.
They meet the neighbors.
Like you know what the hardest fucking thing is just for everybody out there.
Right.
The hardest fucking thing is first of all,
as a guy to actually go to the doctor,
you know,
I'm a typical guy.
He should guys,
right.
So,
um,
they just scare the shit out of you,
if no pun intended about this thing,
because I think the colonoscopy is a bit of a scam because it used to be,
you got to get it when you're over 50.
Then it became 45 now it's 40 and it's like every 10 years now.
The sand to be five now the Santa Fe,
three to five I think they got everything,
but now that every guy feels like it's okay to go in there,
it doesn't mean that you're a little fucking on the fence.
You know guys are so fucking homophobic.
I ain't get it yet.
Fucking procedure.
Hicham guy would just fucking fake.
You'll age.
Right?
Then you did die like Vincent Party.
That's why he died.
He was like,
they ain't putting that fucking thing up.
Me.
Granted it was also the late 1960s they just would have stuck their head in
there and be like,
Yup.
It's like you're going to die.
Camera was way bigger back then,
but way bigger.
It's one of those old fucking,
what are the silent film thing?
Yeah.
It was a crank con with a crank literally inside your body,
and so he took a picture.
It was that explosion with the fucking Chink,
Chink,
Chink.
Then when they took the picture and there was that explosion for the flash,
they had a stick that in your two we got to talk couch.
Yeah.
So anyways,
the hardest thing was,
uh,
the stuff you have to drink is just kind of,
it's like the best tasting medicine.
It still tastes medicine.
And then you just sort of like,
you know,
you can't eat for a day,
but then when you go there,
it's just,
they go,
okay,
here we go.
Here's the fucking anesthesia.
And they put it on yet.
And then two,
you're out,
you're out for this,
you're out.
Ooh,
wait,
I didn't know it was like that.
Yeah.
A lot of trust.
There's a lot of trust.
You're,
and then all of a sudden,
like a second later,
somebody goes,
all right,
you're good.
You're like,
that's it.
That's,
it sounds like a UFO abduction now because that's,
you know,
I will fully went there.
I wasn't walking out into a field of corn pass Ed Gains House.
So if there's anybody out there of a certain age,
like,
uh,
it's,
it's easy.
I'm only guy.
I ever met senior Ufo it target.
And how do you only got a sheet?
Um,
yeah,
so I'm also giddy about that cause I'm on the other side of it.
Next month I'm getting my heart checked out.
This is all being an old debt,
getting the heart checked out during the stress test.
And then I'm actually for the first time I life going to have like a fucking
doctor where I'll go to get a physical every year.
Hold up now are you,
where are you walking on your tiptoes today?
I have a few on there,
buddy.
Oh,
I have no idea that a group of men were looking at my ass yesterday.
No clue whatsoever.
I,
you know what I mean?
It was sort of probably the same feeling like if you got abducted by aliens,
but the next day you kind of know something went down,
but you don't really remember it.
And it's difficult to relate to other human beings
that only lasts for a couple of hours.
Such your doctor.
Essentially the world series tickets fell.
Yeah.
Like,
hey fill this.
Never happened.
This never happened.
No,
I am.
I'm,
I'm thrilled so I don't have to go back.
They said for another three to five years and it's just like,
all right,
so then,
but then what's good dude?
It's like back in the day,
man,
when he got the fucking AIDS test,
right.
And it was just like the first time you got it,
this was every fucking check you would ever fucking Ben width.
And then it's nervous.
Yeah.
And then the next time he got tests,
I,
it's just the last three years,
you know,
so it's going to be the same way at the high.
You know,
I went to Mcdonald's a couple of times.
I've been eating plenty of men,
eaten plenty of fucking Bali or whatever the hell you supposed to be doing.
I've been doing all right though.
But you know,
so I'm,
you know what's funny though is it's still nerve wracking anytime you go to,
I mean,
you know,
that's the,
I'm engaged in.
Awesome.
Good to go.
But to go in and get tested this screenings even.
Oh yeah.
I can't remember the first.
You remember the first yes.
Test you ever.
Yes.
And I hate the coolest.
I have the coolest fucking doctor ever to look on your face.
I was sitting there and he knew I was fine.
He came walking out and he was just going to come on back.
You find you find,
don't worry.
Come on back.
I was like,
thank God he didn't do the scared straight fucking thing where he had me walk
all the way back.
Okay,
we got your results and you know,
look behind door number two.
He just saw it.
He was like,
dude,
you're fine.
You find it's like,
all right,
thanks.
Let me know that you came out the gate.
Yeah,
buddy.
Yeah.
And uh,
uh,
so that was so now that I got that out of the way,
so I'm going to bill burr got after it.
I'm going to,
uh,
I didn't really get after it,
but I went after I went in the wrong areas of society and fucking,
uh,
you know,
I was at guy,
I was standing up during battle.
I shouldn't have done that.
You know,
I should have protected myself a little better,
but that was young me.
Yeah.
That was meat.
Like I grew up in the 80 [inaudible] so I didn't,
I didn't know what it jumped a fence at that point.
You know,
there wasn't a lot of information out there.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
It all,
you're a kid from the 90s,
right?
Yeah,
I gotcha.
I grew up with like fucking insane.
Your jumped the fence is a interesting saying that I haven't used [inaudible]
and backstreet boys.
Oh,
the beginning.
They were like,
if as long as you,
if it was initially considered a gay disease and people who were shooting
heroin,
I remember that.
So there was all these homophobic jokes about it and all of this stuff about
junkies of that type of stuff.
And then who was I?
It was probably Magic Johnson.
And then he's like,
oh,
well he kissed fucking Isaiah and the Gi guy,
old fucking know about that.
It's like,
well,
they do that in France all the fucking time.
Nobody's bagging more women than those guys.
So,
uh,
that,
that was a thing.
Then all of a sudden it had gone into the whole,
you know,
I,
I dunno,
I dunno.
I don't pay attention to stuff.
That's when you,
uh,
you got tested the week after Magic's a press conference.
I got tested,
uh,
mid nineties,
mid nineties.
I did.
And I,
I was in a relationship and she's like,
yeah,
we should both get tested.
I was just like,
yeah,
let's do that all the time.
All the time.
No,
but I remember too,
I came out,
I was,
you know,
had nothing clean bill of health and I was just,
I was site was fucking psyched.
You know,
you got lucky.
Yeah.
You got lucky.
Got Dark Jordan three peat,
Boom Paul.
Oh,
sorry.
That was loverboy.
Um,
that's funny.
Like they should guess,
like,
we know when you get tests for that,
it would be like,
all right.
What bands were you listening to when the high school?
I was listening to loverboy all right,
dude,
you might want to sit out for this.
But anyway,
so I'm a,
I'm so I,
this is some weird way that I'm promoting your album and also I listened to
rush,
so I was pretty clear that was in the clear,
you know,
I heard a rush song the other day that I actually,
uh,
I hadn't heard in a long time.
I really find that man,
it's a great song.
I work in man.
Yeah.
okay.
Sorry.
All I can hear his lover.
Boy,
I'm damaged some.
That's one hell of a mash up.
Do you know how many times I heard pour some sugar on me in the summer of
[inaudible] 88.
I listened to it a lot.
That was the hot video that summer MTV showed music.
I remember as a kid,
I was a little kid.
Look,
mommy,
he's playing the drums with one hand.
I thought it was cool.
I think it's really cool that they didn't fire that guy.
They stood by him.
Yeah.
There's people,
all they do is meth and they're out of the fucking bed.
That guy lost an arm and they're still like,
ah.
All right mate.
Learn how to play with your feet too.
I mean,
they just like,
I mean talk about friends.
I mean you got to thank,
if you lose a F,
I mean if a guitarist lost the armies out,
he's out.
Yeah,
that,
yeah,
you can,
he can,
he can stand on the stage,
but he's,
they're not going to trust them with any solos.
It's a rough one arm grip guy with no arms.
Who plays a mean guitar.
I've seen that somewhere.
I make heat pain.
He has a c as he was use those slide for his big toe.
He uses a spoon.
There was somebody I saw,
I had like a fucking spoon in his mouth or something.
There's like,
whenever I see those fucking things like,
uh,
I'm always amazed by it.
And then also I feel like,
um,
I'm at Coney Island without paying the fee.
There's always like an element of guilt to this.
Like,
why am I watching this fucking person?
You know,
like,
this is,
uh,
you know,
spoon man,
his phone man playing a strong without my hands,
my feet
make me feel guilty for watching yo bone,
man.
I'm sorry.
You know we're going to wait.
Wait.
What we're basically doing is we're just recreating what we do when we're in the
fucking car
as we're driving up to Saskatoon.
Remember when we were in Winnipeg and we are,
we thought they were both Boeing us cause we said we're going to the saxes this
tune they catch kept people in the upper deck just kept going through food,
food.
I thought they were boring me.
I was just like good people up there.
They are good people.
You will,
you were sold man.
I was ready to move.
You ready to move?
Find your wife settled down.
Tune tune tonight.
Get yourself a little farm.
All those creepy serial killer fucking tools that you have.
No one would question and ship.
There you go.
That's right.
One side on the,
is Trump going to make it better?
One side and the uh,
I dunno.
Whatever.
Whatever the fuck it is.
Free ice.
Is that what you get up there?
Just those fucking tons of free ice.
The ice time up there.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
It's all 14 months a year.
Oh No.
And I,
I was in Ottawa.
I was looking,
I go,
what's up at that rank?
They go,
oh,
if you want to skate around your kid.
Oh sure.
Did you bring your boots?
Yeah,
they just had an outdoor rink.
There was some woman out there figure skating during like lunch hour.
And then I'm seeing this little kid,
the mother's like teaching them how to like crossover and shit like that.
And I was just like,
this is why we went at the amateur level,
the gold metal,
but not the pro level because they're amateurs are already in the pros.
And that's,
I think that's,
that's my theory why we always,
we win the amateur one,
but we don't,
the juniors,
sorry,
we don't win the,
uh,
the pros,
it's all that free ice.
We're pretty good despite,
despite the fact that a,
we focus on every other major sport first.
I ain't,
you know,
so that's a good point.
Despite the fact that I think that the tipping point was when roller blading was
as popular as it was.
I,
and then roller hockey started getting going.
I thought then we were going to be able to compete with them and then all of a
sudden one homophobic joke,
different game.
One homophobic joke
it though where it's the same level of tenacity.
No,
it is not.
It's a slower Craig,
if you're going to try to tell me that roller hockey is slower than ice hockey,
I'm going to end this podcast right now.
That's an ease.
If you're going to give me that,
I'm going to,
I'm going to run with that all day.
You played hockey,
right?
Man,
I'm the only guy I ever met.
You played high school?
Yeah,
I played high school hockey.
And uh,
how would,
how would you describe your game average below average?
I started kind of late,
but were you,
uh,
was there a mean streak t game?
No,
I,
I definitely like to,
I liked to uh,
play physical,
you know,
physical guy.
I would,
I would get the crap knocked out of me,
but I would also,
I would also,
well you're not a small guy where you just say your winery back then here,
you know,
I wasn't,
do you have a temper?
Did your ears turned red when somebody checked you?
Definitely wanted to hurt somebody if you know it was full of full contact.
Hockey is the best.
I just haven't played in a long time.
What's the warrants shoulder pads in 20 years,
what's the best you have a got somebody.
Oh my God.
I don't know.
Somebody's coming across the middle with their head down.
I mean you can really,
did they have to leave the ice?
Uh,
I don't think I ever heard anybody.
Um,
do you feel bad at all?
No,
I did not ever hurt anybody.
No.
I never felt bad.
No,
never ever,
ever.
That was like a legal in hockey.
Like if you actually feel bad,
yeah,
you can't,
it's time for you.
They make you walk out.
That's when you put your roller,
you,
it's roller blades
start taking wide turns out there.
He let me tell you something.
I'd like to see somebody set up those cones.
The way those kids do in the park and do those little fucking backwards little s
turns go through.
I've got some go get them kids.
Put it on your little booty shorts.
Come back down backwards.
I Dunno.
I we started to,
it was a little more manly to roller blade.
I mean it gets cause it's so acceptable to play ice hockey.
You know what I mean?
I thought it took a real man.
Somebody who's really comfortable with themselves comfortable just skate
backwards in a park.
You know with your short shorts aren't going around in and out of those fucking
orange cones.
Little comes to,
didn't want to come and speak to big no,
no,
no.
You know you get the little cones cause cause otherwise people think,
you know,
maybe think more of you if you have a regular size construction cone cause she
got even more difficult.
You know what it was used for other things that could be confused for real man
activities.
I know what it is.
What it is is the cone would be so high and he had a hunch down that your ball
bag would be hitting them because you,
your crotch stays right over the fucking coats.
Yeah.
Cause you're so comfortable in who you are.
That's right.
That you're the kind of guy with a big low hanging ball sack that you might gag
that might nick,
one of those tall regular sized cones.
You got to have low cones and you think it hurts to fall on the ice fall and the
asphalt.
Okay.
If
you're man enough to rollerblade in the park with short cones and Spandex,
then you got a ball bag that hangs low enough for you to maybe protect
from what he's saying,
from a taller cone.
I'm,
I'm assigned sign with the roller blade just here.
I'm agreeing.
I'm just saying I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not arguing with your point that it takes a real man to go out in the park,
set up cones,
be secure enough with yourself.
To me,
I might never be bill.
I'm not go rollerblading.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna lie.
I have limitations.
Hey,
I have to promote,
uh,
something.
Aside from your Alvin preferred customer,
what do you sell on this week bill?
I'm selling efforts first.
Family season three is coming out on Netflix on November 29th next month.
Um,
it will be a joyous occasion and I think this is our strongest season.
I'm talking a little shit here man.
All right.
You understand what I'm doing here.
I'm saying that this is the best work we've done and I challenge you to watch
all 10 episodes.
So I get credit for the ratings before you decide that I sneak.
Hey,
here's something else.
You're on a,
you're on a show maniac also on Netflix.
Buddy by the great Jonah Hill.
Huge fan of Jonah Hill.
You,
I like Jonah Hill when he's,
when he promotes something as someone gives him shit,
he tells him to go fuck themselves.
I don't know why more celebrities don't do that.
There's always these little nitpick fucking cunty journalists coming at them.
It's just like,
why?
Why don't you just say go fuck yourself?
He does not say he does it all the time.
Not trying to like put it out there that he's liked that,
but there was some guy just,
he was harping on him about his fucking wait,
no one that he was sensitive about it.
And you just said,
you know what?
Fuck you fucking,
you just,
ah,
I wanted to,
I wanted him to him to the punch that guy so bad,
you know,
take the lawsuit,
take the Wiki and make them all honest.
Um,
and then there's another thing,
a buddy of mine,
Johnny Hickey in a,
another Boston guy.
He so Boston,
he calls you up.
Hey,
what's up doc?
Yeah,
he's like that level Boston.
All right.
He's got a movie called the habit that's coming out and there's a premiere
Tuesday,
October 30th in Redding,
Massachusetts.
All right.
Jordan's Imax.
Tuesday,
October 30th,
Jordan's uh,
imax.
It's a horror movie.
The habit.
Um,
director Johnny Hickey director,
Johnny Hickey.
Um,
and for tickets you can go to,
uh,
oh my God,
the habit premier.
All right.
Is that what it is?
Tickets bit.
Dot l y slash the habit premiere.
Goddamn,
I,
my eyes are just fucking going.
I hope I said that right.
Um,
anyways,
just look up the habit.
Jordan's,
Imax,
Redding,
Massachusetts,
October 30th premiere,
and you,
you'll be able to find it.
Um,
anyways,
so,
so what else,
Nate,
what else can we talk about?
How much time have we done here?
Your Vision's a little blurry because they crawled up inside you with a,
with a crank.
Wayne,
you know,
I would like to,
I would like to think that you'd have a little more fucking empathy for me.
Oh,
Bill,
I'm just trying,
I'm trying to make excuses for your poor vision.
Trying to remind everybody what you've been through.
What I've been through.
I'm the victim here.
Yeah.
Told you literally take a nap and you wake up and the guy's like,
all right,
you're all good and you will feel nothing.
You were all good.
They,
it's,
they got it.
It's a cameras are getting smaller.
The cameras are getting smaller and smaller every year.
Yeah.
You know something that's actually a good point.
Like why didn't I,
yeah,
it's,
it's good that you waited.
I waited till the cameras was small enough.
I'm doing the same thing with hair plugs.
I'm just waiting until they just fucking,
you just throw some fertilizer on your fucking head.
I'm not doing this shit vacuum and stuff out and maybe,
or maybe not.
I'm waiting for when it's 100%.
What are they vacuum?
Well,
they used to take like a slice out of the back.
They'd cut like a fucking like a strip by the way,
dude.
You have,
you have the hair I had when I was in like fucking third grade.
He fucking another reason to download preferred customer by Nate Kraig instant
classic,
um,
and watch maniac and maniac created by Patrick,
some of the Great Jonah Hill.
Jonah Hill handed Jonah Hill never tells anybody to go fuck themselves unless
they deserve it.
It's,
I love Jonah Hill.
Um,
Oscar nominated John Hill.
I heard him on know Howard stern today.
He's got some film coming out too that I'm going to go see.
Yeah,
the eighties or something.
No,
it's about the nineties.
the 90s.
Yeah,
that sounds,
yeah,
I'm going to see that too.
Um,
anyways,
so I got to do what they used to cut a fucking strip out of the back of your
head.
Right.
And then they'd,
it was fucking creepy.
Then they take that,
then they'd sell your head back together.
They take like an eighth of an inch out and then somehow strip.
Yeah,
just that strip.
They were able to seed your like how you getting there is not enough like dead
hair only covered that amount of your head.
This is going to cover the whole top of your head.
I don't know how they did it.
It's kind of like when they see the room fat tricking the rest of your scalp and
the growing hair.
Well these,
the ones in the back,
I guess they're good for life.
I don't get it,
but like as far as I look at it,
it's like now you stick it into the,
the fucking no man's land.
The DMZ,
right?
Like,
like this is like,
I feel like back here is like,
you know,
you're in the United States of America and then like here you just went to
Baghdad,
middle of October.
You might see some fucking action,
right?
You're out on patrol,
you're on point.
So,
um,
the,
uh,
I dunno,
send out someone's trying to claim now like that stem cell shit.
You know,
cause like you fucking shooting like Rogan's always like wrote Rogan is like my,
cause I don't have a real good doctor.
Joe Rogan and his podcast had the great Joe Rogan know.
He does research.
He actually is a very,
very well read guy.
Like he really does research and I'm lazy,
so I just wait to hear what Joe Rogan says.
And I'm like,
oh,
fucking kettlebells.
Kettlebells are the way to go of fucking,
uh,
he's just achieve so much.
We guy was a fucking national champion.
Tyco,
you haven't seen his spinning fucking he'll kick you ever seen that thing?
No.
Oh my God.
Dude.
You'd have to learn how to speak again if you lived it.
It's,
it is fucking ridiculous.
Okay.
Crush that book to Satcom crushed that.
Uh,
fucking did a game show.
Crushed it as a fucking host.
Uh,
crushes it as a comic.
Gets into podcasting.
Biggest fucking podcast.
I mean just why wouldn't he know about stem cells?
Sure.
He,
he,
he's a renaissance man.
I fucking hate now his pod cans.
Your doctor,
he hunts,
right?
Kills Elk,
you know,
it doesn't kill any,
it uses the whole thing.
You go over there,
it gives you like fucking elk meat.
So anyway,
so he's career.
I would love,
I mean imagine being able to call,
you know,
if you got to call your favorite sport.
Yeah.
That's so fun.
No,
and then he also,
the fact that that's as far as like having the best guy fight the best guy,
best woman fight the best woman as far as that goes.
That mm.
MMA.
That's what I feel is what killed boxing was just those guys duck and people for
years and years and years.
And then it's like,
here's,
this is the IBF heavyweight champion.
This is the WBC,
the WBA.
Like back in the day when I was a kid,
there was one world champion and you had to beat that fucking guy to win.
They weren't like three of them.
And then somebody is trying to unify the fucking title and they became like
those fucking superhero movies.
Like after awhile it's just like I did.
These two guys exist at the same time.
How are they driving down the street together?
Who's a good guy?
He's a bad guy,
right?
I don't know.
I never really watched the superhero.
I'll still watch boxing now.
I don't know why I still,
I love boxing,
but it's,
it is obnoxious that they can some home.
Can you imagine if,
if,
if Mayweather and Pacquiao fought when they should've fought and they just had
fucking two or three classics,
Mayweather would have knocked them out three times.
Knock.
Do you think he had that power?
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't mean I don't know enough about it.
I don't either,
but I'm out of my wheelhouse
aside from early Tyson and maybe Roy Jones for a year or two.
He's the best boxer I've ever watched.
I mean,
yeah,
you can't hit the guy.
He can't hit the guy and his left that left comes just real heavy.
Yeah.
I think he would've knocked out my fanny pack y'all a couple of times for sure.
If they had a fight.
Well we ain't.
They should have followed the pot,
the pot shop pot.
How do you think he would have done?
Was he like,
was he a middle middleweight?
What was he?
I don't even know.
Well,
if he was in that division with Hagler Hearns,
Leonard and Duran and all of them took a loss because all four of those guys
were around at the same time.
Now I don't know enough about boxing.
Like what?
I'm going to go out on a limb here and say there wasn't that level of talent,
his division.
So taking that guy back in time,
because I had his big argument one time with Versie about this,
where he verse,
he said he would've beat all four of those guys.
I'm like,
all four of those guys couldn't even beat each other.
How much weight does he have on this way?
Well,
I wish I knew the way class.
let's just say they were the same way class.
The big thing with Tommy Hearns was he was so fucking tall and could make that
weight.
He was like six feet tall or something like that.
You want me whether it beats any of those
skies because the difference in from now and then is significant in the training
and the Diet.
No,
no,
but that's not a fair thing.
I'm saying if every bit they had the same training,
the same die,
they came up in the same era.
I don't know.
I didn't watch,
I didn't watch enough any of them,
but I,
I think that a Floyd Mayweather definitely could,
could bang and stand a pretty good chance.
No,
I didn't think it would be good against any of them.
I just don't know.
Go for no foreign.
Oh yeah.
It's tough.
But they should be fighting all of,
I mean,
yeah,
there should be no cupcake fights,
hair plugs.
I don't,
I still can't wrap my head around how some hair follicles are going to trick the
other hair follicles and growing more hair.
No,
no,
no.
These ones that just like,
okay,
these ones up here are sensitive.
Right.
That's what
these ones back here with raise.
Right?
Like their parents didn't just,
if they fell down they said rub some dirt on it.
They just,
these ones up here were,
I dunno.
I Dunno what happened.
He just,
everything was not there for like the teacher said the kid was a fucking
asshole.
The parents blame the teacher rather than looking at the kid.
Those,
those are the,
that's that hair on top of you head.
So evidently something that I breezed by quickly on the Internet was claiming
that stem cell is close to whatever you're going to go shoot this shit at the
top and I'll have fucking hair like yours.
Of course.
You know my color though,
right?
So I was joking with my listeners that I am doing this.
I haven't quite announced it yet cause we wouldn't announce all the dates.
I have this east,
east Germany,
eastern European tour coming up in January.
And I was saying I'm going to find some Transylvanian doctor and they're going
to fucking shoot my head up.
Right.
And I'm going to be over there long enough and I'm going to come back with like,
like a Farrah Fawcett haircut fall,
black Transylvania and here with my yellow eyebrows as am I fucking freckles?
Yeah.
I'm going to come back looking like Jaclyn Smith,
but the reddit and male version of that.
But jet black hair,
that sounds going to be,
it's going to be and you know it's an Italianate.
It's going to be weird and it's going to affect our friendship,
but I really only think for about three weeks and you're just accepted because
I'll still be meat.
I'll still be me.
I'll still be telling the same jokes.
I'll still smoke a cigar with,
you know,
I could change it.
You're just going to have,
I could change your belt.
In what way?
I don't know.
You know,
send me a full beautiful head of flowing black hair.
I was trying to get a convertible.
I get one of those things like those hearse,
you know those old willys jeeps,
right,
where you can put the windshield down so I can just have the hair blowing the
whole fucking time.
Well,
she see burst hair.
He's not sleeping.
He's driving a hearse.
Now.
I've gotten the vampire route.
Yeah.
And I'll be fucking,
I'll be all gray.
We that it looked like a lost boy.
I'll be a redheaded fucking loss boy.
I got to learn how to say that in,
in Czechoslovakia.
When I walked into the head doctor
and he asked me,
how can I help you?
Right.
I'm just going to be,
I want to,
I want to look like a fucking,
what did I j a redheaded lost boy.
Make me look like I've been here for thousands of years.
No,
I don't want that.
Look,
I know what that look dude,
if I did that and then I started botox.
And do you realize the roles that would open?
I didn't,
I'd have the shiny frozen face.
Right?
You'd have to start working at the casino.
You'd have to sign a contract at a casino.
Oh No,
I don't want to go that route.
Um,
anyways,
so I guess,
I guess I'm going to game format fun.
I'm psyched.
Oh by the way,
the all things comedy,
uh,
podcast,
festival is this weekend out there in Arizona.
I want to thank everybody.
I think it starts up tonight.
Um,
Paul Versey is out there.
I'm going to be there tomorrow doing a live podcast.
Lie Alive.
I do this shit.
Talking to myself,
live in front of a crowd.
I've only done it one other time and I did it in a,
hey,
maybe I'll talk about getting my colonoscopy.
Where are you going to do this?
Um,
and uh,
what's that?
What's that comedy club there and fucking laughs.
What's the,
what's the one there?
Yuk yuks stand up live.
Phoenix knee.
Slappers and Phoenix.
What's it called?
Not the Tempe Improv stand up library and that standup live.
There you go.
Yup.
Bella gut busters.
Good plasters.
What's it called?
They're a funny bone.
Um,
yeah,
I'm going to be doing that and then I be doing a standup show after that.
So,
uh,
analysts,
we'll be doing the goddamn comedy jam.
So I have,
I have to fucking learn how to play a fucking song by then,
man.
God Damn God.
Damn I do.
I got to get them changes down,
man.
Everybody knows,
When you're the drummer,
you can fuck up as it guitars.
You can fuck up on that fit alone,
but you fuck up as a drummer.
Everybody knows that.
Even if they don't know it was you.
They know something hap.
I'm the only guy I haven't met.
Come learn a fucking song on a fucking southwest flight.
Fucking Phoenix,
Arizona.
50 minutes.
I'm only guy I ever met,
took,
took drum lessons on a pontoon boat.
I'm the only guy I've met may drum sticks out of a platypus.
I'm only guy I've ever met.
He makes his
own possum bacon.
You can actually bake,
right?
You can actually cook.
Can you?
I mean I'm,
it's limited my game through down.
You came to the Roosevelt one year.
I thought you,
I thought you threw down.
You made something.
Would you send me a picture?
No,
I've been to your tailgate twice.
I didn't.
I,
I freeloaded both times.
Freeloaded my ass off.
Where you had had yet here when I fell for like 40 gas.
I was right there.
That was perfect.
Sorry.
You wrapped around?
I was losing my balance.
Standing Tent Pole.
You tried to hold on to like,
you tried to hold onto like a foldout tent?
Like it was like a pillar at like a like a shelter.
Oh yeah.
That aluminum thing.
They can try to balance on something that was 15 pounds tops.
I said sorry like 19 times in a row before I finally went down.
Somehow the thing stayed in one place and you kind of wrapped around it.
You fell over a cooler and then slept in a folding chair for about two hours
every year.
I do the power nap.
I knew the power nap.
I remember one year of being so hammered that thing,
I was smoking my Cuban cigar before La headed,
finished the entree shallows and people would just,
I mean I was a mess.
People were taking pictures and they will walk and strangers were taking
pictures with you like you were like a,
like a Marlin hanging out.
They didn't want to go near me.
I,
I remember looking up at some mothers going by with children.
Okay.
And I,
and I,
I didn't understand.
I thought they used to be looking at me with disgust,
but now that I am a parent,
I know what that look was.
That was,
that was actually how do I prevent my children from doing that,
from becoming that?
Because whoever their parents are,
they failed completely.
Um,
I'm only guy I ever met,
got fans in my sleep.
That's a good one.
That's some shit talk.
I'm the only guy I haven't met.
Can't read out loud.
Does it?
Every fucking weekend as podcast
I've got to do fucking,
uh,
I got to do some fucking,
I got to read some shit here.
Would you say season three,
November 29th,
November 29th he's in threeF is for family.
Boom.
[inaudible] where to hear doody or do you do come and watch the shit?
Season three.
All right.
Oh,
hey,
here we go.
Um,
you like advertising,
right?
Nate?
Love it.
All right,
here we go.
By the way,
November 29th I'll be at Zane.
He's in Saint Charles.
Oh,
you will,
you know,
say,
well,
I remember that run.
Is that the world?
Is that when you start,
you start downtown and then you did you do Saint Charles and then Mount Vernon
or something.
That one's close,
but the Saint Charles one,
if it's still open,
I'll be there at 29th which was that Illuminati like sort of like first it was
like this sort of the middle of nowhere.
Like giant ranch stats.
Pheasant run.
That's the Saint Charles.
Yeah,
it's the resort quarter.
Walk to the venue
and you never go outside.
Yeah,
you never go outside.
So if it's a real Midwest casino experience,
alright,
hymns,
everybody,
him.
So it wasn't us.
It was hymns.
Here's a problem.
Oh look at this.
66% of men lose their hair by age 35 look at that Nate year in the top fucking
34% thing is,
is when you start to notice hair loss,
it's too late.
It's easier to keep the hair you have than to replace the hair you've lost.
Is that hairlines slowly starting to move backwards.
Any bald spots yet?
How will you feel a year from now if it's business as usual up there?
Why do guys turn to weird solution or do nothing when they can turn to them?
I was getting slightly offended at this and we can turn a medicine and science.
Uh,
what hymns does is connect you with real doctors and medical grade solutions to
treat hair loss well known generic equivalents.
To name brand prescriptions to help you keep your hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station counter supplements.
Prescription solutions backed by science.
No waiting room.
No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going too far.
hymns.com answer a few quick questions.
Doctor will review and can prescribe you products are shipped directly to your
door order.
Now my listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 today,
right now while supplies last.
See website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy.
Go to four hymns DOTCOM.
Slash bird.
That's f o r a h I m s.com/ [inaudible] for hymns.com/bar oh look who's here now
but it boop,
boop me undies.
Biondi is I'm the only guy I ever met.
Doo,
doot doot me undies,
me undies.
You Ain't seen my fucking dick yet.
I take it out and shake a date.
You face the raid.
No meat too.
When Oklahoma were at a dance and I took you,
sorry.
All right,
me undies.
Uh,
you've heard me obsess over me undies and all the amazing colors and prints they
offer.
But guys,
did you know that me undies also makes the world's most comfortable lounge pants
and t's
well did ya with fall finally here?
Yeah,
with global warming and finally got here.
Now is the perfect time to put these cozy essential to the test fall offerings.
The lounge pants are made from the same micro modal modal fabric as their
undies.
Uh,
let me tell you,
you'll be in fall heaven when you cover your entire bottom half with fabrics.
That's three times softer than cotton me undies also loves celebrating the fall
season with fun Halloween Prince.
Check out their latest jack-o-lantern print him Jack Atlanta,
prince in undies,
socks and bralettes pronounced bralette.
Why don't you help out to say fucking Madell,
I'm the only guy I ever met were Bralette,
didn't get his fucking ass kicked down the bar.
Uh,
the best part when you join me at the membership,
you can get all this stuff,
lounge pants,
taze undies,
fucking elk antlers that you didn't shoot,
but take credit for everything me undies makes for less than anyone else.
Special member pricing is just one of the many perks of joining the membership
beyond.
He's has a great offer for my listeners for first time purchasers.
When you purchase any me on these,
you get 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on.
Um,
to get your 50% off your first pair and free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird that's Biondi stock comp slash.
Bar.
Oh,
Nate,
okay.
You don't need hair plugs.
Maybe your balls and nice and soft and whatever the fuck you wearing right now.
But I have a product for you.
Butcher box.
You ever heard of this shit?
No.
Dude,
I'm gonna take,
this is the best pork chop I've ever fucking had delivered right to my door.
Okay.
Right in my Goddamn skillet.
Seasoned Israeli,
you know,
finished it in the oven.
Took it out.
Give it a fucking rosemary fucking yeah.
Butter Beth.
Unbelievable.
All right.
Butcher box delivers healthy.
100% grass fed and grass finished beef free range.
Organic organic chickens and heritage bread,
bread,
pork.
Now like you,
you're pro like me.
You would probably ask you what is heritage breed pork.
Exactly what I was asking.
You know what the fuck this is?
Evidently these are pigs.
Pure pigs.
All right,
that you can trace the bloodline back to Europe.
These were the original snooty pics.
Now,
like these filthy ones that are all fucking mixed here.
This is like sort of like the Klan meats.
Pork.
I'm only guy I've ever met each royal bacon.
It's royal fucking Bacon,
right from his fucking highnesses Goddamn Lounge.
Um,
do this,
this,
I dunno dude.
This,
it was the greatest fucking pork shop other than I went to a gourmet restaurant
and they really knew what they were doing,
but I'm a comedian and I cooked this thing and this thing fucked with that pork
chop.
All right,
butcher box.
Yes,
right.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets.
Start with the commitment to raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones before they murder them.
All right?
Each box comes with at least nine to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
Unless you're a fat binge eating fuck,
then you'll probably just stick your face in it.
Neat fucking raw meat.
Please try to cook the chicken to all the fatties out there.
Uh,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork,
mixed box,
gender neutral pork.
No,
that's not something.
Custom box.
Antibiotic Hormone fee free butcher box believes in a healthier food system
where everyone has to meets the way nature intended.
Free of antibiotics and hormones and humanely raised on open pastures before
they murder those animals.
Selection,
butcher box.
Carefully cure rates to find a selection and cuts.
It makes it a breeze to customize your own delivery,
build your own box.
They get exactly what you and your family love.
Choose your delivery frequency with the cust.
Customizable subscription recipes are available on butcher box,
website and videos are available to follow along on butcher box,
youtube channel.
Um,
for Free Bacon and $20 off your first box.
Go to put your box.com/burner.
Enter the Promo Code Burr that's $20 off in Free Bacon Promo Code Burr.
Um Oh my God dude,
I got to tell you everything in in there is great,
but I am,
I am a big,
big fucking a pork chop guy.
Uh,
to guess what the fucking Terminex guy's coming.
I got termites in my house.
You got to get a tent put up.
I got it.
I got to get a tent that I can slowly fall around for 45 seconds as I say.
Sorry and sorry.
So lets,
let's fucking wrap this up here.
Nate,
you one of my favorite people in this fucking business.
You really are buddy.
You really,
yeah.
You were raised right.
You know your dad made you refinish that fucking basement right?
Yet you get on your hands and knees and scrub it.
He said the floor wasn't clean enough.
Wire brush,
wire,
fucking brush again.
Do it again.
Came downstairs,
scrape the house.
That's right.
Yep.
And you were down there crying and saying how much you hated your dad and he
didn't let you back up to your fucking finished it.
Right.
He's a beautiful man is,
but I'm just saying real,
real Mister Miyagi treatment.
Oh yeah.
Wax On.
Wax Off.
You have a CD out.
It is called preferred customer.
It's available on iTunes.
I'm going to download it because I support you and everything that you do and
uh,
and my wife loves you.
You know,
usually she's like,
take those animals out back you.
She actually,
let's in the house here@natecraig.com.
We love the bursts.
All right.
Um,
and with that maniac on Netflix,
I'll be at a go bananas in Cincinnati February 7th,
10th.
You got it.
Um,
let's see here.
And then,
um,
before we go to the throwback,
we got,
um,
I called into the sports gambling podcast with Shawn Green home shrine.
Bryan Kramer.
These guys know their shit and I'm just showing green.
I'm just the dope on the show.
Um,
you can listen to my picks for the week.
I'm getting more and more house wifey like New Orleans first of Vikings.
Well I love Bourbon Street so,
and I love drew Brees.
I just think he's a family man.
I'm taking the saints and then we'll have a bonus half hour of a greatest hits
Thursday afternoon just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Have a great weekend.
You can
whoa.
My shotgun
shooting
again.
Shot.
You know,
I just got us start shooting again.
I'm going to shoot
my woman.
Oh,
she fooling around with too many meetings.
Bill Burr on the sports gaming podcast is brought to you by my book.
He died eight g my book is the leader in online sports folks.
He use the Promo Code Bill bets for a 100% deposit bonus play when and get paid
at my bookie.
Dot.
Agee joining us on the line,
courtesy of my book.
He died Agee Promo Code Bill bets,
the one and only bill burr.
Bill.
Appreciate you calling in and we got you away from the game.
Currently,
right now we're taping during a world series game one right now.
The sacs are up five to three.
How are you feeling?
I'm the guy who never feels confident about his team.
I feel like the Dodgers in the last couple of years and haven't been able to get
it done.
So they got a lot of experience and all of that,
but I'm hoping,
you know,
we can come out with a victory.
You're a night,
you know the usual stuff they'll Bellacheck.
I've learned you don't talk trash,
no bulletin board material.
That was always a,
I love that he,
uh,
who is it?
The Patriots receiver that made all those Rex Ryan foot swells.
Yeah,
Wes Welker in that press conference where he just kept calling out the rex Ryan
foot fetish video and then Bella check had to lay the hammer on him and drop him
for a,
I think he made them sit the first quarter.
Yeah,
we lost that game against the jets.
Plus it makes you wonder what,
uh,
Malcolm Butler did before the super bowl as far as like,
what are you gonna do to get sat for the Super Bowl?
But I guess we'll never know.
Find out what you're going to have to do is years later you got to be on a golf
course with some,
uh,
old time patriots or whatever and Shumon summer we'll have a couple too many
courts lights and someone will tell you what happened eventually.
Yeah,
I liked it.
They've kept it in house.
So
yeah,
he had Bellacheck actually did the intro to the world series.
I don't know if you caught that up top.
He did the voiceover for kind of like the hype video leading into guiding voice.
But he's a,
he's an amazing coach,
but his,
his voiceover work kind of monotone there.
I think it's just muscle memory at this point.
Who's like on the team says he's actually a funny guy,
but he's just smart.
Like that's,
that's crap it,
those guys were doing that guy in the Astros who showed a them lighten up.
Was it price or something?
I forget who I figured who that was was a price,
but it was just so,
you know when they went back to back to back against them.
So just looking at some games,
film,
it's just like,
why would you do anything to amp up the other pro?
Because the second you get pissed you're not scared anymore.
It's like,
let him sit there in silence and think about,
I hope I don't screw this up.
You know?
Instead you get them all motivated.
Dumb Dumbo.
That's the most obvious.
Like same tactic in sport.
Just don't talk,
just don't speak everyone.
Everyone gives bell check crap up.
What should he say to the media?
Should he tip his hand as a,
as a fan,
you don't want them giving away any the slightest thing.
Either motivation or strategy-wise.
Why would you ever say anything?
And Sean,
you know,
you know he probably got into it when he was a younger man because for Lawrence
Taylor to respect bill,
it's bill a check on the level that Lawrence Taylor respects bill Bellacheck.
He's seen some shit,
right?
Lt got after a pretty hard there.
Yeah.
I think,
uh,
you know,
I have to reason the media hates us is because we,
we always win and the other half is because bill Belicheck makes him so
difficult to do their job.
Like they loved Rex Ryan.
Rex Ryan was a quote machine and it's just like he just gave him easy days.
He just,
Hey,
I'm not going up dad and kisses rings,
you know,
we're going to win the super bowl.
He was like in Breck shrine.
It was like interview when a wrestler during a Promo or
oh,
he was the heel Trump.
They,
rex Ryan is the football equivalent of Trump.
Exactly.
Yeah.
The article writes itself and Bill Belicheck is just like,
oh man,
I got,
now I actually have to watch the game and come up with something smart to say,
you know,
some sort of analogy rather than just building it around the crazy thing or our
coach said,
yeah,
Rex Ryan made everyone's job easier.
All right,
bill,
what's happened to some of these spreads?
Moving over to the NFL,
kicking things off lines,
courtesy again from my book e.
Dot.
Agee big game here in New Orleans.
Head into Minnesota right now.
The Minnesota Vikings.
A one point favorite at home.
Which way you lean in here.
I love drew Brees and I love New Orleans and I like to drink.
Sound like Tombow.
You can't,
you can't beat that Combo.
Yeah,
off the Bourbon Street.
I got some places you can,
your ego where the locals go.
You don't go to a purpose street.
That's,
that's Times Square of New Orleans.
It.
Hey,
hang out with ido and eat some chicken on a stick and a gas station.
Shawn.
Yeah.
This is,
I mean,
there's a huge revenging or here,
right?
Oh yeah.
I mean,
New Orleans coming in after what happened to knock them out of the playoffs,
that miracle in Minnesota,
the way they lost that game.
I mean,
they were the,
obviously they should have won that game.
Total collapse.
New Orleans coming in on fire five and own their last five.
But more importantly for,
and one against the spread.
This New Orleans team,
I think if they gonna slip up,
it was,
it was going to be against that ravens seem right,
but they played well hung in that game.
And this team just seems the,
in the NFC right now,
it's just gotta be the same sort of the rams.
Right.
I mean they,
they seem like they're really firing on all cylinders.
Yeah.
I'm going to play the regression angle.
Everyone's seeing the superego and vikings.
I'm going to go vikings.
Um,
I'm gonna,
I'm not gonna,
I'm gonna they're pros.
I don't think there were the prevention things real and I think this Minnesota
defense has turned it up of late and uh,
yeah,
everyone's kind of forgotten about that sick home field advantage and I think
it's coming back so well.
New Orleans normally not good on the road,
but I mean it's another dome team.
I think this is a decent spot for him.
Yeah.
All right.
I don't believe in that
matches anymore unless it happened the same season with the image of three
agencies and how much everybody hangs out each of with each other at a barbecue,
which is not the way it used to be.
Yeah.
Everyone's,
you know,
hang it,
tag,
you're tagging each other on the gram and shouting each other ad,
especially in the NBA,
the NBA,
it just feels like one big rec league where there's just,
okay,
there's one team that's clearly going to dominate and then everyone else,
he's just kinda having fun hanging out.
Yeah.
It's like a warehouse playing softball against each other and it's really just
about going on,
having some beers,
you know?
Yeah.
They may as well turn the NBA into a beer league league at this point.
Uh,
it's got
crazy.
Nobody,
I mean,
what was,
I think he's on Instagram video of a dunk where there was anybody.
Seriously challenging.
So first of all,
you're not even allowed to be in the paint and all these kids know,
Oh man,
I'm going to be on the gram.
So Dude,
you should get your head taken off,
but not,
not,
you just keep,
I don't know,
it's just completely,
everything is completely different game.
Like,
did I talk to you guys about that Kansas City Patriots game?
No,
I don't.
I don't think we talked about that.
But uh,
yeah,
that like that right there like that is not football.
I like watching two people playing a video game with lives.
People like the fact that that number 10,
I always forget his name,
whatever else name is on Kansas,
he's killing you the whole game.
There's a minute or two minutes left,
you know that going into him.
Not only does he score,
he ran across to sealed,
he runs up the side that untouched but like 70 yards.
I get the guys fast.
But no,
she just,
she just ran out there like it was,
you know,
the coach's son and there was something out there.
Hey,
nobody touched them on this play.
It was like a make a wish a moment.
Juvenile diabetes come on and he's living out his dream.
And to the point about how the leagues have gone soft.
If anyone hasn't listened to Charles Oakley,
discuss this on the Simmons podcast,
he really just keep calls it.
He's like,
yeah,
it's a,
you know,
back in my day we just fought.
He's like,
when we said we were in a fight,
we fought nowadays,
who knows?
That doesn't mean much,
you know,
like [inaudible] I don't know it.
Well,
and then,
uh,
and then Tyree got the beer poured on him by,
one of the paths fans and that was a disgrace.
That was it.
That was the whole big thing.
And it,
uh,
my buddy actually,
it kind of reminded me of the malice at the palace and a,
my buddy actually sent me,
Bill has a great bit about it back in the day when it happened,
about how awesome it was to just see a professional athlete go up into the
stands and beat the shit out of a shitty fan.
It's,
it's really as,
listen,
the wrong guy,
that was the only thing that sucked was he got,
he did get the wrong guy,
but you know,
some I liked everybody was like,
oh,
real classy creatures fans.
And everybody forgets that the Yankees,
you know,
uh,
through the,
through there in a relief pitcher this year when they called that home run,
uh,
banner to Faron.
So whatever,
whatever the hell happened on that.
Uh,
that play,
I can't remember.
The New York capers were trashing the red sox and they made that kid for the
Yankees,
played Baltimore way back in the day and he reached over was a basket catch.
I think they made that kid a local hero.
Yeah.
Jay Jeffrey Mayer.
Was that his name?
Uh,
and,
and I,
I would say this as a compliment to,
to red sox and even eagles fan in Philadelphia fans.
There is that element of like,
yeah,
I grew up going to red sox,
Yankees fans,
and you know,
I saw a dude like fall from the middle deck to the lower deck.
Like,
dude,
things got thrown.
Like that's part of the game.
Everything's just cha.
I mean,
I know out here it's about bringing knives to the game,
but there is a certain,
there's a certain beauty in like the,
the,
the flying near bottle,
simple beer toss
and the most would be going to gain for the world series this year.
Awesome.
As a red sox fan and I will be dressed like a undercover cop.
I will not have any red sox stuff on.
I just,
I don't still need it.
It's just out here.
It's just not fun.
Made that mistake I made,
I made that mistake one time.
Wore a don Mattingly who,
you know,
most people,
most people say even if you hate the Yankees,
you like Donny baseball.
Where am I?
Don Mattingly,
a Jersey to the bleachers.
The all you can eat bleeds.
Hears that at dodger stadium.
Bad move,
multiple,
multiple food items thrown at me during the game.
You're going to a place where they have unlimited ammunition.
Ryan,
it was fun.
My favorite thing is when you're literally getting threatened,
bodily harm and curse that and the,
and it's by some dude and he's there with like,
he has like three kids under the age of eight.
Yes.
Like what are you doing?
What are you teaching these?
These,
these kids.
You turn them into animals and it's just,
it's just how it is out here and it's straight across the board.
Like it isn't like a,
I guess if you sit down in the bleachers,
it's,
I mean in the box seats it's a little bit nicer,
but it's just like,
I don't care.
Like,
you know,
black,
white,
Latino,
I don't care.
It's just straight across the board.
These people out here are just like,
no,
we're going to kill you.
It's like,
it's like,
all right,
well that was,
that was a fun first dating.
I guess I'll go down and get a hot dog and sort of meander around the stadium to
get away from you guys and I put my hat in my back pocket.
But
it's,
it's such a weird dichotomy because you think of La and you don't think of like
passionate sports fans,
but then,
oh yeah,
we'll randomly murder you over a baseball game.
But what weird,
weird,
we're building a great stereotype,
I believe.
Sports fans,
right?
They were
casual
escort us out in a San Diego chargers game,
uh,
almost got killed at a gun,
threatened to be stabbed at an angel's game.
Wow.
By then I'd learned my lesson.
I'm like,
these people are like out of their minds,
you know,
and then,
some Celtics Lakers,
crap.
I,
you know,
a Celtics Jersey,
Paul Pierce Jersey in the upper deck,
bad move and move you Irish state issue where I wish that chowder Choudhary and
the whole damn thing.
Uh,
by the time I went to a Raiders patriots game,
I was just like,
I'm just going to wear a black tee shirt.
And uh,
in a,
in a ray like a,
I dunno,
a ll bean hat or some big dress like dress like Ellen degenerate or something,
I'm going to go to the skate complete politically neutral.
It's a funny,
of course we had our first,
I never in all my years of going the east coast football games,
never saw someone break a beer bottle with the intent to stab another human
being.
Yup.
First football game we went to,
it was San Francisco at the old part.
Yeah,
a Raven's niners game.
Who's sitting in traffic trying to leave the game and Bam,
we almost witnessed a murder.
It's just,
it's,
it's much more hardcore and the game was a hilariously bad game.
It was 12 to nine there was no touchdown scored and maybe that's what got them
all work
and would actually doing fans of service because this story is not told at all.
You know,
is the eagles through batteries.
It's,
it's Santa Claus and Blah Blah Blah.
Eagles and Chili and Chili and show Austin in New York.
Yeah.
Yes,
but no,
you,
you can get killed out here.
We got to cut a PSA.
Hey Listen La,
you think it's a casual sports stamp but you can get murdered over the wrong
jersey.
All right,
speak.
Speaking of La,
the Los Angeles Rams there at home,
laying nine and a half points to the green bay packers.
Aaron Rodgers
just ram it guys ran that knife into my ribcage.
Cut,
slice my cheese head up.
Uh,
I dunno,
a quick sidebar Sean,
but I don't know if you've noticed,
but some of the TV,
the local coverage of the rams.
I think because they
weren't so good in the beginning,
didn't
change anything and some of these guys just don't know football.
It's pretty hilarious to watch this shit.
It's like,
this is nothing like a east coast like postgame show.
These people don't know anything about the game.
They're not even rooting for the team.
Like what the fuck is this?
It's a long way off.
But all that being said,
I'll take the rams ln nine and a half.
This team's all fire.
Aaron Rodgers though.
This is his,
uh,
the biggest underdog he's ever heard.
Like the biggest underdog spread of his entire career.
Bill House a year.
Are you going to get on that
pack?
Aaron Rodgers,
he's one of those guys.
He loves his send kids home crying.
And the opposing stadium,
but he gets up for it.
He plays great on the road.
And uh,
I dunno,
I looked up some numbers on this one.
Package defense isn't that bad?
I don't think,
you know,
I dunno.
I that's a tough one.
Just all of those points and Aaron Rodgers,
I and his competitive ways I would,
I would,
I'm going with that.
What am I am a standup comedian.
What do I know?
I'm not trying to get stabbed in la because I,
I picked the packers.
I'm sorry
you liked the packers to cover,
but you said the rams are when now.
Right.
To clarify if anyone had any uh,
undoing.
They just have too many weapons there and so does the people in the crowd.
Thank you
Karima.
Which way you lean in.
I mean it's,
it's an awful lot of points for one,
Aaron Rodgers and,
and no matter the deficiencies they might have on fence.
This is,
this is,
even if they're down,
this is backdoor city.
Aaron,
Roger's not going to be giving up and Sean,
75% of the money on the Los Angeles Rams,
they got to lose at some point.
Right?
Maybe this is the week,
hypothetically and yeah,
you gotta think that Aaron Rodgers and going on a little brother Jared Goff.
Imagine Aaron Rodgers like,
I'm not losing to this bitch.
I am not losing to this little bitch.
Well,
golf is a w wait,
golf came from what school?
Cow.
Also maybe their buddies.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
You know,
I think he's,
I think Aaron Rodgers wants to prove he's the real cow.
QB.
Oh,
little a little revenge gears Rogers older than McVeigh.
I think he's gotta be cosmic phase like 32 yeah,
that's crazy.
That's really crazy.
All right,
last game of the slate here.
New England patriots facing heading into Buffalo.
We're right now over at my bookie dot Agee.
The buffalo bills are a 14 point Monday night home dog d journeymen.
Derek Anderson starting again.
I love that phrase.
And also love.
They say he signed off the street as if he was just wandering around.
He's starting at quarterback for the pills.
Lashawn Mccoy.
It looks like he could be out.
Bill,
do a to the pats.
We're all here or do you,
you think it's close enough that the bills are worth the taking a shot with the
points?
I hate 14 points with the division rivalry and you're on the road.
And also the bills are so schizophrenia this year,
this is,
this is one of these issues.
One of these trap games,
Bill,
suck right them all day one 27 nothing against the Vikings and the next week
they get killed or they were up 27.
Nothing gets vikings.
I,
uh,
I'm gonna say,
um,
I would,
I would take the bills and the point simply watching last week when we played
the damn bears and we had them,
we should've put them away,
should have driven down the damn on my old bed and kicked a field goal open up
by,
by three scores.
Instead we ended up,
you know,
when we came within a half a yard of going into overtime,
that was a crazy hail Mary to get to the one yard line.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that's that whole thing like you stick,
you stick a wide receiver down there.
He's not going to try to knock it down.
It's going to try to catch it.
That guy that wasn't Gordon,
the guy we got from Cleveland and he did not even though,
what did he,
he,
he was,
he was a,
he was out of his element.
Uh,
they might want to run that play with him a couple of times.
So I think the Patriots are going to win,
but I don't,
I don't numbers too big there.
I will say in the end they go into the prevent and it screws over the gamblers.
Who uh,
who checked the Patriot,
which 14
crime or not to mention Sean night.
First of all,
97% of the money coming into the page.
I'm like,
it's early,
but it will be Monday night.
This bills,
this bills fan base will have nothing.
This is the,
this is a super,
super bowl,
right?
There'll be breaking tables.
The grows will be out there breaking tables with them.
There's,
there's,
there's no doubt of that.
And Buffalo strength is their past defense.
So I could see the way they play,
the way MacDermid sits in kind of that soft coverage that a,
well Brady might pick them apart.
The receivers are going to take hits.
Sean,
it's,
it's a low of 38 that night.
So yeah,
of course you're taking 14 right?
Even with Derek Anderson,
what could go wrong?
What could go wrong?
There's no way.
37 to five certainly there's blowout potential here,
but uh,
I liked the
now
talking sports,
Bob though,
talking sports while watching sports.
Hey,
it's the,
it's the life of a sports fan,
right?
Last point,
Sean.
Yes,
because I'm also on the bills.
Guess who the Patriots have on deck?
The packers coming to tell,
oh look at head game apps.
They look ahead spot.
I don't know.
Packers aren't that good.
Kind of a stretch.
But pets are pretty disciplined,
but still 1414 point Monday night home dog.
This is,
this is their Superbowl.
They're going to,
they're going to be fucking going crazy in buffalo.
So I think he got to take the big number there.
Okay,
great.
That's a great point.
Yeah,
great point.
I like that.
I went to a game and I had a patriots hat on.
They were playing the judge.
I was rooting for the bills and I had made the mistake of going into the mental
narrowing that God just started getting all this crap and they waited til I
started to take a leak and somebody pushed me from bye.
That's dirty.
That's a low blow,
but they don't try to kill you.
They,
they're just,
yeah,
they're more like a,
you know,
just like,
I don't know.
They just want you to bathe.
Bathe in your own urine.
Yeah.
They're a class.
Your fan base,
Chic shot artists,
Sarah and Buffalo.
By the end of the year,
I want to label all sports fans so we're animals or the east coast.
They're killers on the west coast and that cheap shot artists in buffalo.
All right.
How many more markets do we have?
Bills Mafia to go through it and sold each market.
The Midwest is coming?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I don't know what they tried to bang your wife into the cheese or something?
Yeah,
we'll figure something out.
Some tainted beef.
All right,
Bill,
as always,
appreciate you calling in and as always,
big thanks to my bookie daddy g Promo code bill pets for a hundred percent
deposit bonus.
Uh,
use that Promo Code Bill Bets in game wagering,
props,
live betting.
They got it all over at my bookie,
daddy g and a make sure you check out bill burr and uh,
the all things comedy festival heading to heading to Phoenix this weekend,
October 25th to 28th.
They know he got a lot of a Phoenix listeners,
so if you haven't gotten tickets already,
make sure you go check out the etc. Crew over there.
All right,
Bill,
I appreciate you calling in man.
Yes.
Yeah,
it was fucking raining on this.
And one thing I've learned that when you go to a football game and you're
dealing with the elements,
this is the more of a douchebag you look like the warmer you're going to be.
All right.
I saw the rain and I said fuck this.
And we went right to Dick's sporting goods and I'm like,
I'm buying that fucking,
I'm going to buy a raincoat with the matching raincoats slacks.
I don't give a fuck.
I bought a pair of a wool socks and I was good to go.
So with [inaudible] and you know they only had like two rank coats left and they
were the exact same color.
This fucking grapes,
slush puppy purple.
So we both have matching extra large fucking,
we got the jacket and the pants like we're working at a fucking airport and what
green we're bringing in the fucking soul plane,
right?
That was a purple airplane,
right.
That's what we look like.
So we show up to the game,
right?
Neither one of us has comfortable because neither one of us is a jets or a bills
fan.
So we're in enemy territory and a,
it's fucking drizzling and out.
It's fucking cold.
So I proceed to put on this Barney the dinosaur outfit,
right?
And right off the bat,
Versie starts punkin outgoing man.
I'm just gonna.
I'm just gonna wear that.
I'm just going to wear the top.
I'm just going to wear the top,
trying to act like it's not raining out that bad.
The reality is is he didn't want to go through the hazing that he would have to
if the two of us walked in with our purple on Purple fucking raincoats times
too,
we would have got a ton of shit and I was prepared to take it.
I had an,
I had a whole fucking silly walk I was going to be doing.
I don't give a fuck.
So he punked out.
So,
uh,
we ended up walking in and put my head's cold,
right?
All I have is a baseball cap on.
So I'm like,
fuck,
I got to buy a hat.
Can I buy a bills?
Who gives a fuck?
They were in last place mangled by a bill's hat and then I saw this,
this one with the Patriot logo on it.
I said,
fuck it.
I'll get that.
Once I put that one on,
I'm nice and warm.
We go to,
we'll call,
we pick up our tickets.
We go into that high school football stadium that they have out there that I
actually love,
looks like an old school football stadium.
You know what I like about that football stadium that's about the size of a
football stadium that holds real fans.
You know what I mean?
All these,
these new ones that hold like 100,000 fucking pets,
all the bandwagon shit hits.
You know when you're all in for the real fucking fans show up are all in three,
right?
So he walked into the Goddamn stadium.
We love in life,
right?
I'm already laughing at Versie cause I know damn well what's going to happen?
He's going to walk out there.
There's going to be some shitty little plastic seat that's going to be covered
in fucking water and the only way he's going to be able to absorb it is through
his God damn jeans and his fucking DVDs.
And then he's going to be sitting there with a wrinkled up nut sack that's going
to be getting hypothermia by second quarter.
Why do I know this?
Because I've been there.
So we get a couple of beers.
We get this fucking beef on a stick or whatever the fuck they call it.
We're good to go.
We go in there,
sit down,
he sits basically down in a fucking puddle.
He tried to stick a newspaper down,
which is very absorbent.
And uh,
I don't know.
We sat there and I had hope for about eight seconds in that game and the jets
came down and just fucking shit.
They just kicked the shit out of him.
Christ,
they kicked as shit out of 'em and uh,
it was just over.
So we,
so immediately our solution is just to start drinking the way we drank at the
masters.
We're like,
fuck it,
let's,
let's get going here.
Right?
So we'll make a trip after trip and all of a sudden I gotta take a Piss,
right?
So I go and I'm standing in line and all of a sudden this,
this fucking six foot,
five goofy looking jackass,
one of those guys who's like six foot five,
but you still think he can take him cause he's just covered in baby fat.
You know,
he's got a couple of whiskers on his chin and his cheeks are rosier than Saint
Nick,
right?
And he's got this Jersey on and this big stupid,
I'm a buffalo bills fan with the horns on it and stuff.
You know,
he's the Wacky Guy,
so I'm not even thinking shit.
Right.
This is bill's jets.
I don't have a dog in this fight.
I'm not talking any shit.
I'm fine.
I forgot I was wearing my patriots hat.
And all of a sudden this big goofy jackass starts going,
well,
what's what?
Yeah,
well you're a patriots fan.
He liked the rats.
We got to Rancho and the rats,
he likes to fucking rats and the shit,
right?
And I'm like,
yeah,
no,
whatever.
He starts giving me shit.
I start giving him shit back then the weirdest fucking thing happened.
I,
by the time I get in to the actual men's room,
I've talked,
I've given these people so much fucking shit that actually,
there's bills and jets fans at a bills and jets game.
They're playing each other.
They stop giving each other shit and they teamed up together and started giving
me shit.
Right.
And then I just said,
I don't know what I was thinking.
I felt like I was on stage cause it was like a crowd.
I wasn't thinking like,
Hey,
you know what bill,
you really haven't had a fight outside of your family since maybe playing some
fucking street hockey in the sixth grade.
I didn't give a fuck.
I'm in a God damn bathroom waiting to take a piss in a goddamn trough by the
way.
And uh,
and then they just started giving up fucking this one dude such going,
Tom Brady Sucks Dick.
He Sucks Dick.
And he's like miming it like ridiculously wealth.
So I'm like,
ain't nobody do that real wealth because I learned it by watching Tom Brady.
Mike.
Oh yeah.
Do you rent that porno?
You fucking fag gets a little uglier,
gets a little uglier than this other dude.
What the fuck did I came up with the hell he was saying to me and I just said,
look,
I'm sorry you guys have never won a super bowl,
you know?
Then the jets fan pipes in.
I go,
do you realize the last time you guys won a super bowl,
Charlie Chaplin was still alive?
Do you understand that?
Do you know what cars look like the last time you won?
You fucking morons.
And then uh,
then this other guy go up until we've won three Superbowls.
I'm sorry.
Right?
And then the guy goes,
well,
you didn't play in the games.
I go,
neither did you.
Then he's just standing there with this dumb look on his face.
Like,
oh,
that's right.
I keep staring forward.
You've got nothing forgetting that I don't know how to fight.
So all of a sudden it's my turn to pes.
I take my dick out,
I'm ready to Piss and one of these fucking pussies push me in the back hoping
that I was pissing at the time.
Fortunately I wasn't.
So I turn around,
I put my dick away cause I'm a gentleman.
I said,
I go,
is that how you guys do it out here?
Really?
I go,
which one?
You guys pushed me like I'm gonna Fuck,
I'm fucking Jackie Chan.
And for some reason,
none of them said anything.
I don't know if it was my purple on purple rain coat or the look of fire in my
eye,
but I'm a fucking 42 year old,
balding redhead talking shit in there and none of them said anything.
So now it's kind of funny to me.
I felt like I was in like the world series of poker and I went all in and I,
and I didn't have a hand whatsoever.
So I don't know who the fuck pushed me,
but that's what I mean.
Come on.
Bitchy is mover the fucking week.
How'd he do that?
How do you do that?
How do you,
how do you push another man when he's got his Goddamn Dick out trying to piss it
to a fucking trough?
I mean,
how do you get lower than that?
Do you guys have any ideas?
How do you get lower than that?
So then after none of them said anything,
I go back and I started taking a piss.
And then that other dude who was miming somebody's sucking a
dick unbelievably well right next to me.
One of those stupid hats that has the toggles on this side and he's still trying
to give me shit and I'm going to add,
go fuck yourself.
And then he just starts screaming over and over again.
Are you looking at my Dick?
You looking at my deck like maniacally,
like five times.
I just sort of stared at him like,
why do you keep going with this gay angle?
Like why is there always a,
I dunno.
I think he was one of those guys.
He was kind of in the closet and then,
uh,
so he just goes to football games and he gets really drunk trying to just kill
the families there.
I think he liked me.
It's what I'm saying.
So if he's listening to this,
I'm sorry,
uh,
I'm,
I'm spoken for you fucking pants.
You fucking believe that.
First of all,
what's wrong with me?
I really replay it,
all of that in my head because once I got out of there,
I was like,
I really started thinking like,
what?
What did you think you were going to do in there?
They're not Clint Eastwood yet saying things.
Clint Eastwood would say.
What?
What the fuck is wrong with you dude?
Like I don't know if I've said this before in a podcast,
a public bathroom is the worst fucking place to ever get into a fight.
There is nothing soft.
There's everything is porcelain pipes that concrete floor and then it has a mist
of piss and shit.
It's just a fucking,
it's the worst.
It's the worst place ever.
You know,
not to mention it usually starts evidently when one person as begun,
the pissing processing.
Okay.
So,
uh,
you know,
older,
little bit wiser.
So then I'm standing in line to go get some more alcohol cause God knows that's
what you need after an incident like that.
And I was just kinda just sitting there thinking like,
all right,
now how should I have played that?
It w it should have ended when the dude with the water buffalo hat started
giving me shit.
What I should've done was roll with it.
I should,
you liked the patriots.
I should have been like,
hey,
you know,
you guys scored 30 on his last week.
Man,
you guys look great man.
I,
I bet the jets,
I mean,
I bet against the jets.
I hope you guys should have just ended it with that and did it.
I sh I should.
Uh,
I should have extended an olive branch.
That's what I should've done in the future.
That's what the fuck I'm going to do because,
uh,
that was a,
a,
that was a potentially ugly situation.
But fortunately,
um,
I think the people who were doing it,
you know,
had jobs and no one wanted to get sued and no one was willing to take it to that
level.
Uh,
and when I say fortunately,
I mean for me in my face,
oh,
do you know how bad that have been to get stomped
in that fucking purple on purple rain coat lay in there with my dirty fucking
patriots' hat
and my team wasn't even playing.
I would have lost the lawsuit.
They would have been like,
let me get this straight.
You're a patriots fan,
you're a patriots hat to a bill's jets game and you somehow manage to get the
shit kicked out of you.
What the fuck did you say?
You know,
that's one of the great things about being a guy is you actually have to take
responsibility for your,
for your actions.
See,
a woman would be like,
there's no excuse.
There's no reason.
I don't care what happened.
You don't hit a girl,
which is true.
You don't need a fucking girl.
But there's no learning in that.
There's no lesson.
You know?
Even my best friends would have been like,
yeah,
those guys are fucking assholes.
And the Bun,
you know,
that would've been an awkward pause.
I'm going to be like,
dude,
what the fuck he talking shit for by yourself at a game when your team isn't
even fucking playing.
What's wrong with you?
You're 42 years old.
Get your shit together.
And they would have been right.
Yeah.
Yay.
In bed
Friday.
They want what?
Shed.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
October 25th,
2010 how you doing?
What's going on?
Um,
I just got back from a,
a awesome tour,
a quick three,
four day tour,
three nights of a wonderful theaters.
I feel like a big shot.
I worked the Wilbur Theater in Boston on Wednesday doing a fund raiser.
Okay.
And then I did the Pantages theater in Minneapolis,
Minnesota.
One of the most underrated cities I've ever been to.
Minneapolis was the shit.
And I was bummed that I was only there for a day.
And then I went to a Chicago and played the Vic theater,
which evidently Dennis Miller did one of his recent specials that,
you know,
I loved the Toad Babe.
I love the toad fucking quick.
Wait,
what the fuck?
And a chip bag,
you know,
one of my favorites of all time.
Um,
so I got to stand on the same stage.
I guess they did some HBO half hours there.
I heard a talk that Bill Hicks had possibly perform there.
So it was a,
it was an amazing night tour,
I should say,
not.
And of course I had the wonderful,
uh,
teen idols sensation from the opiate Anthony Program.
Joe Derosa,
Rosa opening for me the entire time.
And,
uh,
believe it or not,
I hung out with Joe to Rosa and did not have a drop of alcohol.
All right.
Now I know a lot of you are familiar with Joe to Rosa.
For those of you who aren't.
Joe Is,
um,
how do I put this?
Joe is a drunk,
um,
in every sense of the word.
He literally,
you know,
the amount of times he can't find his keys and passes out in some sort of fetal
position on the stoop of his building.
It's just,
it's,
it's really just something I'm starting to get nervous about,
you know,
and I'm sort of codependent.
So when he starts coming around with his fucking half of Egyptian WC fields,
red fucking knows the booze usually starts flowing.
But I don't know what happened.
I got back into the zone.
I got back into the fucking zone of not Busan.
I had a had to Heinekens and I know a lot of your beer drinkers will be like,
well,
that,
that'll do it.
Dude.
It's too fucking better,
too hoppy.
Um,
I had a couple of Heinekens A,
I dunno,
we could go last Saturday night.
I was like,
you know what?
I think I'm fucking sick of this.
Yeah.
You know,
I think my head is about big enough.
I think it's,
it's,
I think it's pretty much,
can't even say waterlogged alcohol log,
you know?
You know,
that's where I really figured out why I don't like boozing is because drinking a
ton of beer is the male equivalent to when females bitch about retaining water
and they just feel fucking bloated.
Me,
be honest with yourself.
It might not happen the day of the tailgate,
but a couple of days after the wings and those fucking Goddamn 16 ounce beers
you were drinking,
you just wake up in the morning,
stumble into,
go brush your teeth and you're like,
whoa.
You just look at that fucking,
and my head is the size of like a fucking industrial like cookie jar.
If they made one,
and I was sick of it and I haven't posted in like seven days and I'm noticing,
uh,
or eight days or nine days,
I'm up to nine days here.
It's kind of,
it's starting to fucking shrink a little bit.
And I already had a fucking big goddamn head to,
the last thing I needed to do was to be adding Chins to it.
You know,
it's not even when you see a guy who was always sort of jolly will say,
rather than I'm,
I'm in a good mood this week.
I'm not going to say he's a fat fuck,
we'll just say a jolly guy.
Right.
Um,
you know,
his whole life,
Husky,
you know,
healthy well that dude,
you see him a five,
10 years later and his head's even bigger year expect it.
But for me it's,
it's when you see that the,
the bean pole guys,
he's a couple of celebrities out there.
I don't name names on the podcast,
but there's just one in particular who back in the day it looked like you could
pick 'em up with two fingers and just walk them over to a table,
you know,
and,
uh,
saw him the other day and it's just like,
dude,
you know what it really is?
I think it's because it has to do with not being married,
believe it or not add.
It's bullshit.
Because what if you're married to the wrong person,
then it can be depressed,
you'll be eating.
I don't fucking know.
All I know is I've,
I've,
I've figured something out here is far as where if I'm going to continue boozing
I'm going to be doing it and it's definitely in the hotel lobby of wherever I'm
staying at because that is a much more mature place for some of my,
someone of my age to be at.
If you like make and you travel a lot and you keep trying to visit your old
haunts places that you'd go to when you were in your 20s,
possibly your early thirties that you just can't do it after a while.
You know,
you walk in and you know,
you just look like the date rape drug guy.
I mean why else?
If you're not the club owner,
how else do you honestly think something's going to happen in there?
Right?
So what you want to do is you go to the hotel lobby and there what you will find
is a unhappily married people
and some call girls.
You know,
I sat there stone sober with Joe to Rosa.
We actually hung out one night and did not drink the night of the,
uh,
the show at the Vic theater,
which was fucking unbelievable by the way.
Um,
place was sold out and I cannot thank the people,
the good people of Chicago enough.
That's a great fucking city.
That is a great God damn city.
You know,
fuckers know how to eat,
they know how to drink,
they know how to grow a mustache and they won a Stanley Cup.
They were in a great fucking mood and I went up there and had an awesome set.
But anyways,
so we hung out at this,
this,
um,
hung out at the hotel lounge and we were just laughing about how pathetic our
friendship is when you remove alcohol.
We sat there,
this is a fucking dude I've known for seven years and the fact that we weren't
drinking and breaking balls at that hour of the night,
it was like an awkward first date
just sitting there other than just making fun of how we had absolutely nothing
to talk about.
And that's when we just started looking around,
looking at the people look like that movie up in the air someplace.
I Clooney's character would hang out.
And we're just sitting there laughing,
trying to guess the jobs that people are doing,
you know?
And then all of a sudden these two fucking knock outs out of nowhere come
walking by and you know,
so I do what you always do.
You fucking look at them,
you know,
look at him right in the eye and this is what gave him away.
They didn't look away.
And I was like,
oh they're professionals.
Wow.
This is a whole,
there's a whole new environment.
I got to admit I liked it.
The music wasn't loud.
It was totally geared for a 42 year old loser like myself.
And I really enjoyed myself.
I didn't had a water and I ate a case of dia and I,
uh,
I don't know.
I had a great fucking time,
so I'm gonna see how long I can go.
I'm really going to,
I'm going to try to go until the rose bowl cause you know,
you know my rule,
I got to start the year off right by just making a complete ass of myself at the
granddaddy of them all.
So if I make it that far,
that'll be 76 days sober.
Saw break my old record by one day and I won't,
I won't put it so fucking far out of reach that when I start drinking again,
I won't feel like I can't get back to,
you know,
maybe 77 days.
All right.
Was that boring?
Good.
This is the new sober me.
I got no stories from the road.
I'll,
let's talk about uh,
Minneapolis.
Why Minneapolis was the shit.
I actually,
uh,
I got an a day early and um,
ah,
God damn it.
I don't have my phone on me.
I did a great radio show.
I forget the name of it of course,
because I was half asleep.
Phenomenal fucking interview.
And um,
I'm actually going to start listening to the show online.
We'll have this information on the [inaudible] podcast.
I just kind of woke up and did this podcast so I don't have my fucking phone
with me.
Um,
and then I actually,
I took a tour.
This is how much of a sports Goddamn nerd I am.
I took a tour of the twins,
knew a baseball stadium.
The target,
uh,
target field do target fucking owns Minneapolis.
All right.
The way Jp Morgan owned Manhattan back in the day when he used to walk around
with his top hat and his shoes,
what those fucking white things around the ankles to let people know that you're
fucking rich.
Target owns that Goddamn city.
But uh,
if you're in Minneapolis,
you need to kill a couple of fucking hours before a flight.
I suggest taking a tour of a target field before they close it down for the
winter.
It was awesome.
It was a fucking great ballpark.
I definitely want to come back to Minneapolis and uh,
it's another one.
They had good food.
They had a,
all of this whole strip of restaurants.
And then where I played the pantageous,
they had a whole strip of theaters.
They had whole little scene going on.
Great bars.
You know,
that I stood in not drinking,
having drunk people from the show coming up to me,
you know,
talking to me,
realizing that this is what you look like.
Bill is a little life lesson,
but I,
I do,
I do have to criticize Minneapolis about one thing.
Uh,
I walked by one of their,
uh,
their bus stops and I guess it was a major bus stop because it was 40 people
there,
40 of the brokest look and fucking people I've ever seen in my life.
Okay.
White,
black,
Asian.
I don't give a fuck what race I,
there was no connection to make.
Like how this level of brokeness happened.
I walked by,
I was actually nervous.
I was like,
someone's going to slug me in the head and tried to take my fucking wallet
because if I looked the way these fucking people looked,
I would do the exact same thing.
I saw a meth couple.
I don't know what they were.
He's dirty,
uh,
looking people.
The girl looked like a,
I don't know.
She was high on something and they had a baby.
She had a baby.
Man,
she fucking baby sitting there right by the,
uh,
the bus stop.
It was just a,
yeah,
but you have to just want to rescue a baby that like abduct them.
You know,
you just rescue them.
Like you would've got damn dog and one of those Sarah McLaughlin commercials.
Why don't they have a commercial?
Why can't you do that?
If you see a meth couple drugged out couple,
you know,
and they're sitting down on the fucking sidewalk,
like they are laying on a bed with fresh linens with a fucking baby,
you know,
I wonder what they would charge you with abduction.
But I,
I'm how much,
how much of us,
any lawyers listen to this shit?
How much time would you get if you just so like,
look,
the fucking baby was being neglected.
So I took it.
He could get away with that shift.
You really couldn't.
They'd be like,
well,
why didn't you call the proper services?
Uh,
cause I don't know what that would involve looking shit up and trying to find a
number.
I went with the,
uh,
the immediacy of just fucking taken him.
All right.
I believe I've meandered enough.
Here's,
here's a couple of comments from past white,
uh,
white pass,
podcast.
Uh,
this one's called the white man,
what I call it.
Uh,
oh,
someone said,
uh,
hey bill,
I'm behind in podcasts.
So you may have already gotten emails about this,
but Christopher Columbus was actually a redhead.
I was making fun of Christopher Columbus a few weeks ago in Columbus Day.
And,
uh,
this guy saying Christopher,
oh,
I remember when I said,
I was saying how Christopher Columbus actually,
he had blonde hair in my history books.
So this guy is saying he was actually a redhead.
I think throughout history,
anyone who decided to walk,
sale,
fly,
swim toward toward inevitable doom at the end of the world was inevitably a
psychotic ginger.
That would have been good.
Can I give you some,
uh,
tips on joke writing?
Don't use the same word and the setup and in the punch,
you said it inevitable twice.
And of course I'm reading it so that really kills it.
Now this goes back to my theory of,
uh,
when they,
they talk about new information throughout history.
When exactly did they suddenly discover that he was a redhead?
Did you find some 600 year old whore who actually used to bang them
and she was just,
yeah,
he actually,
he had red hair carpets match the drakes.
Um,
that's like the,
that's like the fucking,
uh,
the,
these,
these black tubes who was standing on the corner of Minneapolis,
uh,
you know,
all those guys who scream about religion,
do they ever have like the levels of their pa a juxtapose correctly?
They always talking way too loud.
Yeah.
Have,
and you know what's funny is half to white people who walk by,
they probably think that they're getting,
making that face like disapproving of the message rather than the level of,
it's just Jody get a new fucking PA.
Yeah.
Get a fucking God damn,
uh,
whatever the fuck you call the person who knows how to run the board,
make it a clean sound.
Okay.
And send it,
been like,
yeah.
Excuse me sir.
Not trying to interrupt your hate.
Um,
I just,
it's really difficult to understand what it is I'm supposed to be offended by
when I can't understand what it is you're saying.
Um,
journal rows,
it actually said to the Guy Jesus was white and one of his,
his,
uh,
terminator x guys actually laughed and then another guy stared at him and then
he went right back to the,
uh,
fuck white people face.
Once again.
Another classic example why I stay away from organized religion because it,
it leads you to that,
you know,
Jesus loves everybody,
but he's our color and he loves us best,
but he loves everyone.
What,
um,
anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
I'm sure that bothered a lot of your ears.
I apologize for that,
but that's literally what the fuck it sounded like.
MMM.
Okay.
I would like to do that on a street corner.
Have a really bad pa like that and just be saying a bunch of fucking reverse
racist shit about white people.
I wonder if anybody would get it,
the amount of people who wouldn't,
that was what would make it really hilarious.
Yeah.
But he's white.
I don't understand.
Um,
all right,
here's a quick question that I got this week on Peyton manning a bill.
I am a college student in New York City and I love the podcast and your comedy.
I am a diehard giants fan and the kid down the hall is from Indiana and is a
colts fan.
For some reason he feels the giants were lucky to beat the 18 and oh patriots
and that they flat out suck.
Um,
but Peyton was not lucky to win against the rex Grossman led.
Here's your fucking Superbowl coats.
Chicago bears.
I need you to go on another rant to explain these two super bowls and which one
was more legitimate?
Um,
all right.
First of all,
you're,
you're playing into his hand.
All right?
He's just deliberately saying,
shit that's going to piss you off and,
and you're,
you're taking the bait.
All right.
The giants weren't lucky.
The giants are actually,
the 2007 giants are arguably the most underrated Superbowl team of all fucking
time because everyone was so fixated that the patriots lost.
That was the story rather than
the giants had one of the most undeniable championships of all time.
They were on the road the whole time.
They went down to Tampa Bay,
they beat Tampa in Tampa.
Then they went to Dallas,
beat the cowboys in Dallas,
then they went to green bay and beat Green Bay in fucking Green Bay.
And then they went to to uh,
uh,
the Superbowl and for some reason with 17 point underdogs to a team that they
scored like 35 points on a month earlier,
still kicking myself in the ass that I didn't take that bet.
Um,
and fucking just,
you know,
blasted the Patriots right in the mouth,
kick their fucking ass.
Didn't really kicked our ass because of the score.
But as far as like when it really came down to like a,
just the offense,
the defensive line just crushed our offensive line.
I mean,
I don't know.
I don't think they're underrated at all.
I actually don't feel that the 2007 giants get the respect that they deserve and
it's a fucking shame that the patriots hadn't lost just one game.
So then maybe they could have focused on that.
And He,
my theory is if the Patriots actually just lost the game during the regular
season,
maybe they could have just,
they could,
uh,
actually had a weekend to themselves and not at a bunch of cameras up their
assets.
Um,
anyways,
so I,
I totally disagree with that,
but I think this guy's just trying to piss you off.
And as far as the,
uh,
the colts play in the bears,
I mean,
it's not their fault that the bears,
that the,
all these other NFC teams couldn't beat fucking rex Grossman,
if I remember correctly.
Rex Grossman,
anything beyond 12 yards was a hail Mary.
Am I crazy thinking that shit?
Am I crazy?
This whole call be throwing up these motherfuckers,
these motherfuckers loaded Packard shit.
Can a black quarterback,
what the fuck that,
um,
anyways,
yeah.
So all he's trying to do is just,
uh,
he's just trying to piss you off and you're allowing that to happen.
And um,
you know,
I don't,
I'm amazed that you are allowing that to happen because,
uh,
you know,
say what you want about rex Grossman.
He didn't throw a pick six to lose the fucking game.
He just kind of threw a bunch of shitty passes for four quarters.
All right.
Um,
speaking of which,
um,
I want to talk to San Diego charger fans this week and,
uh,
I want to know what the fuck you guys did to the football gods.
Okay.
Now this,
this is a group of people that,
uh,
evidently we're rivals with something that I wasn't aware of,
um,
because we usually beat them,
you know,
which always amazes me why Yankee fans,
back in the day hated red sox fans.
It's just like,
why would you even bother?
Why,
why did you even notice I,
he was the difference between us and the fucking,
you know,
the Goddamn twins at this point,
we always lose to you,
you know,
back in the day.
Um,
but anyways,
like the amount of fucking times that the chargers have beaten the fucking
patriots and still lost the game is just,
it's just,
it's fucking beyond me.
You remember that one year in the,
uh,
I believe it was the playoffs.
Playoffs.
Um,
they like stopped us.
We were down,
I don't know how many points we were down,
but we would down,
it was the end of the game and they stopped us on fourth and short fucking games
over.
All they gotta do is take a knee and run out the clock,
but some fucking idiot on their defense gets like a,
a personal foul on the play,
completely unnecessary,
which gives the Patriots have first down and allows them to continue that drive
to then go ahead and,
and steal the fucking game.
Now,
yesterday wasn't the same scenario.
That was a case of the Patriots blowing the fucking game.
But it's like you're right there to tie it and you know,
if you tied it,
you're going to beat us.
You got a 45 yarder,
which is totally makeable by this guy.
And then someone on your offensive line has of a fucking false start.
Five yard penalty.
Now it's a fucking 50.
Yarder I gotta be honest with you.
I saw it.
I thought that that guy was going to miss the 45 yarder.
Uh,
he just didn't have that.
I'm going to nail this look on his face.
But then I thought once that guy got the five yard penalty in the,
became a 50 yard kick,
the fact that if he missed it,
it was good.
People were going to be blaming the fucking cunt and the offensive line.
I figured maybe that took the pressure off it and he was going to hit it and lo
and behold,
the guy kicks it plenty of fucking leg.
And you know,
and just typical of the torture of that,
these I feel San Diego charger fans do not deserve at this point.
They have paid their fucking dues.
He didn't even have the decency to just kick it fucking wide.
Right.
And you knew the second was off his foot.
You could be like,
ah,
what the fuck?
Right.
It's the whole way.
You will,
you couldn't tell either way.
Is it gonna is it gonna be good?
Is,
is he going to miss it?
It actually hit the upright and does it bounce in somehow miraculously,
and they tie it up.
Now it just fucking falls to the ground kick is no good.
And,
um,
San Diego fans.
I want to know what do you think you did?
Cause I remember back in the day when the red sox would blow it and they had the
curse of the Babe,
you know,
at least we had something to,
to,
to try to blame it on.
What did you guys do out there?
Was it because,
uh,
was,
was there a group of Indians,
they're having a good time and then fucking Mr San Diego came in and fucking
raped and killed all of them.
The name that area after himself.
Is that what happened?
What happened out there?
Oh by the way,
this in,
in this week's,
this week's,
um,
or this month,
I don't even know if rolling stones monthly or weekly,
um,
edition,
they have that dead dude from entourage who plays the manager on,
I'm sorry,
it was in sports illustrated and they asked him how he felt when the red sox
came back in 2004 and beat the Yankees and he's a big time Yankee Fan.
And he goes,
I was happy.
I was happy that they finally won it cause I was so sick of them.
Listen to them complain.
How fucking hilarious is that really?
Where you're really happy.
Oh,
I was glad you guys want really,
we use sick or rubbing our noses.
You fucking lying piece of shit.
You was sitting at Shannon 1918 with all of them.
Jesus Christ.
That's like fucking Regis Filburn.
After we,
after we won it,
he was like,
yeah,
you want it.
You want it all right.
Whatever.
Enough already,
you know,
move on.
Fucking faggot.
Yankee fans,
this such pussies.
All they can do is talk shit for fucking all this time.
And then the second it comes around for them to talk and Shit,
they got to act like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
I'm happy for you guys.
Yeah,
I'm happy.
Stand there and take it.
You fucking midget.
Whatever the fuck you Goddamn name is manager on entourage.
You weren't happy.
You were fucking pissed.
You had your head between your little fucking midget knobby knees.
Oh,
it was after the happy you guys want when the Yankees win.
I'm never happy I have the balls to fucking admit that.
All right there.
Fucking little man with a better career than me.
All right then let's plow ahead.
Um,
it's amazing that we,
we still won and his comments still pissed me off.
I wanted misery.
I wanted misery out of those guys.
Oh,
speaking of which,
I don't even know what's going on in baseball.
I know the Rangers won.
Congratulations.
All right.
Which once again makes me wonder what the fuck the people of San Diego did.
Cause here it is,
the people at Dallas are just,
you know,
now I'm ready to blow my fucking head off that God damn Tony Romo kick fucking
complete.
If the fucking play calling,
you know,
they're going nuts down there.
All right.
And here it is.
Baseball,
sports.
They don't even give a shit about,
actually,
wait a minute.
The longhorns are always in fucking the college world series,
aren't they?
But that's way down there and fucking Austin,
but whatever.
It's like the cowboys,
a shit and the God damn bed.
And,
uh,
then all of a sudden the rage is come on,
gives them something to fucking share above.
So,
I dunno actually liked the Phillies and I liked the giants at,
uh,
I guess just because the giants having one in so long,
I'd like,
I'd love to see the rangers first,
the giants,
and I think I'll actually watch the God damn world series.
I actually,
when the Rangers started kicking the shit out of the Yankees,
I started,
you know,
peaking into bars and watching it because I was amazed that a $55 million team
could have such a great lineup.
And what sucks about baseball is half those guys will end up on the red sox or
the fucking Yankees,
uh,
which really has to stop or am I completely full or,
or am I completely full of Shit?
Because despite the fact that the fucking red sox spent all that God damn money,
did they make the playoffs?
No,
they did not.
And could the Yankees beat of $55 million team?
No,
they couldn't.
And plus I'm also is finally starting to read all this shit about these other
fucking cheap bastard known as like the God damned guys with the pirates who
just make a profit every year and don't even try to make,
put a winner on the field.
I think the whole God damn sport needs to be rehauled.
That's what the fuck I say.
Rehauled or overhauled.
Do you know I was watching the,
uh,
this is just a completely random podcasts.
I was watching the Jersey shore last night though the final episode and uh,
I just love how they fuck up sayings.
Sneaky said.
She was upset about something and said that her blood pressure was off the roof.
My blood pressure's off the roof,
not going through the roof,
not off the charts.
It was off the roof.
God blessed that big titted fucking you don't,
she's going to be a great mother.
I don't know what it is about her.
She's going to be a great mother,
but she,
I don't know if she's ever going to get married because so much footage exists
of a,
I don't even know if a lot of footage exists cause I didn't really watch it this
year,
this season.
But you know,
once you do like a fucking whatever that,
that backwards cartwheel that you did and they have to pixelate you pussy lips
hanging out of your fucking Thong.
I mean that,
that you're really limiting the amount of people that are going to want to go
out on a date with you.
Something that she continues to,
to,
uh,
to bitch about.
You know,
her tits take up her entire torso.
If you notice that they start right under Adam Adam's apple and they go right to
the top of where her pubes grow.
Um,
which is another thing that's working against there,
but you got to admit she's got a lot of talent.
Her ability to do that back flip and not like,
what are those fucking things?
One of those weebles wobble,
but they don't fall down at some point like that.
That should be like impossible for her to do.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
What am I talking about this week?
Um,
yeah,
so the fucking patriots won.
I think we're one of the weakest five and one goddamn teams out there,
but we're five and one tied with the Goddamn jets.
What do you think about dead u green,
Bald fucking cunts?
Um,
anyways,
oh,
this week,
by the way,
let me hype some,
uh,
some of the shit I got going on.
I have a,
I'm going to be going to,
um,
Saint Louis this weekend.
I'm doing a benefit on Friday night and on Saturday night I'm doing two shows.
One night only at the funny bone is Saint Louis.
I haven't been here.
I haven't been there in a,
put it this way.
The last time I went there was the first year of new Busch Stadium,
I believe.
Yeah.
Whenever the fuck that was,
it's,
it's been a good five,
six years I want to say.
I don't know.
It's been a long goddamn time.
So please come out to that show.
I will have my new DVDs for sale and I can't stress how much you're going to be
happy if you buy that God damn thing because comedy central,
because they actually make their money through advertising,
had not their fault,
had to cut out 16 minutes of that special plus an extra five minutes because the
special is an hour and five minutes long.
So with the 60 minutes of commercials plus the extra five minutes,
21 minutes of that special you have not seen.
And the overwhelming response I've gotten from people was like,
Holy Shit,
I can't believe they cut out all this stuff.
I mean,
I get why they did it.
I wish they showed it over 90 minutes and you could see the whole special,
but um,
you won't be disappointed.
And I have extras actually filmed one of my Monday morning podcasts.
If you're ever curious to see what I look like sitting in sweatpants,
talking into a mic by myself.
We got that footage and some footage of me getting heckled and giving people
shit back.
All right.
So that is an anam hanging around to go to the fucking rams game,
the rams game,
which will be my 101st professional franchise that I have been to,
uh,
trying to go to all 123.
And this,
this week I actually,
when I was on the plane,
this is how I'm,
I try to uh,
kill time when I'm on the plane is uh,
I dunno,
I,
I try to,
if I write down the,
the teams that I haven't seen,
this is really psychotic.
I'll do it with my right hand cause I'm a lefty,
right?
Trying to develop that skill because I feel like my brain's turning to mush
talking on cell phones.
And uh,
this week I actually,
and I'm,
well I'm going to complete this list and put it up on the [inaudible] podcast.
I actually,
um,
started to compile a list of the names of all the stadiums that I've been to.
And a,
I got to admit it's pretty,
it's getting pretty fucking impressive at this point.
Some of the classics that I've been to,
some of the ones that aren't there anymore,
like Old Tiger Stadium,
old Yankee stadium.
Uh,
and even like the random like county stadium.
Remember that one with like the brewers back in the day when they used to hit
home runs,
every time they hit a home run,
they had this big fucking titted whore would slide down into a slide into what
was supposed to be an old school keg of beer,
you know,
I dunno.
So good God damn time.
Um,
so I'll have that list up there.
Seriously.
If you ever sports nerd,
if you'd like,
if you don't,
if you're not into it,
who gives a fuck?
Um,
all right.
This podcast is grinding to a goddamn halt.
All right,
let's get to some advice here.
Bill.
I met a girl on a online dating site and uh,
we hit it off and we both thought each other
as friends.
Now,
you know,
usually I,
I blame myself when I,
when I don't read these well,
but this,
this one is really not written well.
He misses words and he misspells the,
the rest of them.
So just bear with me.
Alright,
so basically this guy,
I met this girl on an online dating site.
They hit it off and they both think of each other as friends while over the last
nine months,
we became good friends.
Even after I moved eight hours,
eight hours days,
you mean eight hours away.
Oh,
you got a job and you're working eight hour days.
I have no idea.
During the last three months,
um,
she lost or last 25 pounds,
lost 25 pounds and told me,
uh,
she was bipolar and Oh,
oh geesh.
Jesus Christ dude.
Okay.
And over this time she keeps calling
and started treating me like a boyfriend.
So obviously you're fucking her.
Okay.
So you're,
you're hanging out with this girl for eight months and you're banging her.
So yeah,
she's going to start treating you like a boyfriend.
A few weeks ago I was invited to her family's beach house for the weekend and
met her whole family.
While I was there,
her mother introduced me to their family and friends as the guide Jane has been
dating for the last four months.
I blew it off.
Why would you blow that off?
I guess her mother could,
you know,
it was just trying to save her a daughter's reputation.
Hey,
this is my daughter's a friend friend with benefits.
Yeah,
he's banging her,
but there's really nothing going on here.
Oh,
these kids today.
Um,
I blew it off and enjoyed the weekend,
uh,
three weeks ago.
It's,
uh,
it's gotten really bad and I'm trying to distance myself.
And the other night I asked her if she thought of me more than a friend and she
said no.
And it gave me the friend speech and then ask why I felt that she might have
felt this way and gave me some examples about calling me
on.
Then she gave you some examples about calling her all the time and telling a few
other personal things.
Well,
two days later she called me and said that she can't be friends with me anymore
because every time we talk or hang out together,
uh,
it gets tougher because she's always going to think that she,
she's giving you,
she's giving,
oh,
giving you the,
I like you more than a friend vibe.
Um,
I feel really bad and that what I said might have caused her to have a major
episode what like bipolar episode and we talk so much,
I didn't really realize how much of a part of a life my life she was and I did
have feelings for what do I do?
All right.
First things first.
This is why that friends with benefit thing doesn't work for so many people
because friends with benefits,
if you're hanging out with someone of the opposite sex,
they're going to start getting feelings for you.
So the only way to do the friends with benefit things is you can only,
you can only bang.
Um,
and but what you have to do is there has to be a significant period of time
between you,
you banging that,
you bang them and then you fucking leave.
But inevitably something like this,
someone's going to get,
get some feelings in.
It's,
it's an impossible thing to do.
It's like what you're doing is you had a one night stand and you,
you are either through being selfish or just lacking the confidence of you being
able to pull off,
getting laid again.
You try to keep,
I can only speak of this from the male side,
you try to keep this person in you in your fucking,
uh,
in a holding pattern around your life.
And uh,
yeah,
of course she's going to end up catching some feelings.
You're going to end up hurting the person.
You can't.
I mean,
if you're just friends,
what the fuck are you going over meeting her parents for?
You know,
like that level is shit.
No matter how much you've said from the get go,
that,
look,
I don't want anything more than this.
We just,
I just view you as a friend.
If you go over and you meet her parents like that says something.
All right.
So my advice is,
is if you liked this girl,
make her your girlfriend.
If you don't like her,
stop fucking her because you're hurting her.
You know,
that's all you're doing is because she's gonna forget about the fact that she
has these,
this by bipolar disorder or whatever.
Now obviously,
I don't know how that fucking plays into it.
Um,
but yeah,
dude,
you gotta you gotta man up and have the balls to either make this girl your
girlfriend or man up and just be alone,
which is how most people I think fuck up their dating careers and getting
married and all that is just,
they have a fear of being alone and they don't want to,
uh,
just ride out that fucking six weeks.
You know,
going through the first few days of spooning with your pillow and crying and
feeling sorry for yourself and just learning how to pick yourself up off the
mat.
Join a gym,
right?
Get yourself in shape,
hang out with the fellas,
watch some games.
You know,
it's only
being single,
really just,
it sucks on days off and it sucks at night.
But other than that,
it's a,
it's pretty fucking awesome,
you know,
to just kind of be able to walk into places,
scope out every chick there and be like,
I want to try to fuck her.
Or maybe that's the girl I want to marry.
Like that's,
that's a great situation to be in and it's worth the loneliness.
Come on,
be honest with me.
How many people out there are fucking with somebody right now you don't want to
be with and you're going to these family fucking advance.
You know when you just feel the noose getting tighter and tighter around your
neck.
I'm telling you,
just get out of it.
And when you get out of it,
go through the pain of being single on,
of,
of going through the breakup.
Don't just go out and run back to the person.
Don't fucking go out and just start dating somebody else and just use that
person to fill up your fucking loneliness.
Like really just be alone.
And when you,
you know,
I'm telling you,
you have to fucking couple of weeks,
you're going to get through it and then
you'll be comfortable being by yourself and then you can have a quiet fucking
mind that isn't thinking panic thoughts and he can just kind of make a list of
what the fuck you looking for,
you know,
and ask for if you don't know what to,
where to find it,
asked for some goddamn advice.
But the last thing you do is,
uh,
is,
is get involved in a situation like this where it's like,
dude,
if you really gave a fuck about this girl,
wouldn't you when you made her your girl or maybe you're afraid to make her,
her,
your girlfriend?
I don't know what,
but,
uh,
that's my advice.
I would do one or the other,
actually commit to this girl and try to make it happen.
Um,
or just get away from her.
All right?
But I got to admit,
you're really taking on a hell of a fucking thing here where you've got someone
with a bipolar disorder.
You know,
and I hate to say it,
but you have to be selfish when you're picking a mate and it says that something
you want to fucking deal with except something you feel you're capable of
dealing with.
This is the shit you have to ask yourself when you sit in there alone,
you know,
eating Doritos with one hand down the front of your fucking sweat pants.
All right,
there you go.
I think a lot of that made a little bit of sense.
God dammit.
Somebody sent me a picture the other day,
this guy at a,
a pickup truck and on the back he had all this shit.
Um,
Anti Obama.
Obama is how you say his name,
Obama.
And uh,
at one point he had this,
uh,
this is what fascinates me about people who are straight up Democrat,
a straight up Republican.
It reminds me of people who are into like fucking organized religion,
just like the blinders that they have on this is the bumper sticker.
This guy had had,
he said,
recession,
your neighbor loses his job,
depression,
you lose your job recovery.
Obama loses his job,
you know,
and it's just like,
that was fucking people.
It's like,
how do you not see that they all kind of do the same thing and they're all on
their knees blowing the same fucking,
I mean,
don't you see?
Okay,
Clinton,
Democrat,
liberal,
right?
Bleeding,
heart liberal.
What does he do?
The bleeding,
heart liberal.
He's for the fucking everyday Joe.
He's just going to give it away to the broke people.
What does he do?
He helps deregulate the banks.
All right.
George Bush comes in,
right?
He wants to help out fucking major corporations and all that type of shit.
Doesn't give him one war.
He gives him two wars
billion dollars a fucking month or whatever the hell it is going into those
fucking cunts pockets.
God,
in the combination of those two fucking moves,
the deregulation of banks trying to fight to fucking wars,
to away games.
By the way,
on the other side of the fucking planet,
bankrupts this goddamn country.
Obama comes in,
right?
Bleeding,
heart,
fucking liberal.
What the fuck does he do?
Gets us out of Iraq and then escalates to shit and Afghanistan.
Has he taken any of these bankers to task?
They stole a trillion dollars.
They can't even say the way the fuck it is and who got it.
Is he going after those people
now than not?
It's the same fucking people,
which is why I resent people when they tell me when I vote for Ron Paul,
Oh rain or anybody else,
you know,
light of that ilk who saying that these bankers and these corporations are
completely out of fucking control and we need to do the audit,
the Federal Reserve or maybe even close to the,
you know,
shut the fucking thing down and they,
they're not allowed to debate and they're just considered a crazy person.
And then you go out there and you basically make a decision between the two
fucking guys that they're giving you to vote for,
that you feel like,
oh,
we made these choices.
You didn't,
you didn't.
It's all the same fucking guy.
Hi.
He didn't figure that out in 2004 when your choice was two white guys who both
went to Yale,
who were both a member of that fucking group,
the,
the skulls or whatever.
It was the same fucking guy.
And I love how these,
the fucking Democrats somehow get,
get off a guy,
get away with being like a,
you know,
they're all like millionaires.
Like John Kerry was a fucking God damn millionairey made somehow he's going to
be a man of the people.
I don't fucking know.
I think,
uh,
I think at a lower level,
I think you can actually affect change
in political office.
But I think once you go past a certain level,
I think when even when you get to,
like if you,
if you were like a senator of your state,
I don't,
I just don't feel
that,
you know,
I dunno.
I think Obama said a bunch of shit that he was going to do,
got into office,
saw how shit works.
And right now he's trying to prevent getting shot in the fucking head.
And like everybody else who gets that job and you just,
you just do what they want you to do.
That's my,
that's my fucking 2 cents.
But these fucking morons who will,
will come along and just sit there and blame the current president if they're of
course,
if they're not a member of their party,
it's just beyond me.
It's just fucking beyond me.
Like,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
But,
um,
but like I said,
I feel like I've,
I've talked about that enough on this fucking podcast.
People are still coming at me not understanding,
understanding what I'm saying about these,
these automated checkout machines at the grocery stores.
Once again,
this guy writes me like a five page fucking email talking about pulleys and
levers and inventions from back in time.
Like I'm against fucking,
uh,
um,
progress
and he's comparing all of this shit.
I'm sitting there going,
fuck airplanes.
We should be back riding horses.
What about all the Black Smith who got put out of business?
I'm not talking about that.
I don't want to ride a horse to a Gig and fucking Philly.
I don't want to do that.
I love airplanes.
I don't have a problem with that shit.
I'm not talking about progress.
I'm talking about something
that,
that makes me have to work for somebody for free.
That's what I'm saying.
All right.
If they came out with those automated checkout machines and it got rid of
people's fucking jobs and,
but,
but I walked up there and it was like this thing that just,
just magically could tell me what I fucking owed without me having to do the
actual fucking job that the other person was just doing.
I wouldn't have a problem with it,
but those fucking check that just all they did was turn the cash,
register around and now I have to do it and bag my own shit.
How the fuck that progress.
Somebody else was trying to tell me that it's all part of this movement of,
of it was really,
really a spiritual thing.
So that we'll have all these robots,
man,
and they'll be doing all these jobs and then life will just be all about,
you know,
just exploring life.
Cause you won't have to do a fucking job.
It's just like,
it's like,
dude,
you're completely ignoring
sociopath's
all right.
Which is why like when,
when,
uh,
as much as I lean left,
I don't go all the way to the left because that's the big flaw in,
in,
uh,
psycho level of,
of liberal thought
is you completely ignore sociopath.
If everybody says nice,
everybody,
everything would be nice.
No,
it wouldn't.
They'd still be Charlie Manson.
It's still be those guys.
They'd still be that guy who couldn't handle
not fucking having more than somebody else there couldn't,
or the person who can't feel anything unless he's fucking poke in the eyes of a
squirrel out.
So I don't know.
My,
my,
my theory has always been that fucking hasn't always been that way.
Just just through the fucked up shit that I've read.
And God knows if it's even right,
is that sociopath's basically run the fucking world.
You know,
they have the balls to just go out and take and they have the,
the,
I don't know if it's a chemical makeups,
psychological makeup,
whatever it is to feel absolutely no fucking guilt.
They could give a fuck about other human beings.
They could give a fuck about nature.
They could give,
they could give a fuck.
They could give a fuck.
So
Jesus Christ,
I was,
I'm still on my God damn soapbox.
I didn't know what the fuck I was talking about.
Oh,
getting back to that shit.
So that is my,
I don't have a problem with ATS.
Okay.
Htms I basically became my own fucking teller.
But here's the big difference is I then had access to my money.
24 fucking seven you gave me a little something.
I don't have a fucking problem with that,
but I walked into a grocery store and now I'm standing behind a fucking plumber
trying to scan a week's worth of God damn groceries.
It's not quicker.
It's not.
It's,
it's sucks.
Fuck you.
I can't stop sending me fucking emails about pulleys and levers.
Jesus fucking Christ the advent of the wheel.
He fucking 30 fucking 40 PC.
Ah,
kill yourselves.
All right,
my recorder cut out again.
And it wasn't the batteries this time.
The memory was full on it or if you're of the spiritual ILC,
I think it was the podcast.
God's telling me to stop being so fucking preachy.
Um,
fuck the podcast gods.
All right.
I'm not working for fucking free.
I'm not doing that.
Those God damn automated.
Uh,
um,
things there when you,
when you go into a parking garage,
now I've got to stand in two fucking lines.
I gotta stand behind somebody.
They try to stuff their crinkled up dollar bill and trying to pay for their
parking and then I got to dry and you know,
then I drive down waiting to leave and they don't get to just fucking leave
cause they got to make sure they paid it.
They,
all he did was create an extra line and you eliminated the fucking parking
garage guy and now I've got to sit there and wait for the person to,
oh wait a fuck did they put the ticket that said I paid twice as God damn long.
That's what I'm talking about.
Pulley and lever guy.
I'm talking about inventions that do not make my life easier.
They just make me work for fucking free.
And the time that I spend in the store is not any shorter and a lot of times
it's a little bit fucking longer.
That's what I'm talking about,
sir.
All right,
here's a reference to last week I brought up chipped beef on toast.
Somebody from the military let me know that that's actually known as shit on a
shingle.
Um,
another here's another classic white trash meal that I had.
You guys ever have chicken Allah king that was like sort of chipped beef on
toast without the chips of beef.
Another classic white trash meal that I had most white trash meal.
What it involves is some sort of sludge put on bread because all it is it when
it's real,
it's not about nutrition.
What it's about is taking away the pain of hunger.
And I mean,
you could literally wallpaper a room using chicken,
Allah king as your wallpaper paste.
That's how disgusting that Shit was.
Um,
I don't even know what it was mixed with.
It was sort of this gray.
I'm not quite liquid,
not quite solid.
It was like a great,
not a,
I got overly thick fucking gravy.
I mean it's one of those,
do you remember that when you took,
uh,
not to gross people out cause this is really,
you know,
getting kind of gross here and when you would open the can of chicken,
Allah King and you would turn it over,
it would sort of slide out.
It would just be,
and before it,
it finally just dropped down on the play to be,
and then there was like that,
that,
that sort of transparent gelatinous shit on the bottom of it,
which just was fucking
disgusting.
Yet somehow we weren't obese as kids.
It's because we were outside playing.
I think that gradually,
the only good thing with,
uh,
with those video games now where they are,
if you play soccer now,
you actually got to sit there,
swing your leg around and running and stuff.
I mean,
I guess,
uh,
I guess that's a good thing.
Right?
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Bill.
Uh,
he actually,
I got a thank you letter,
which is always nice because ever since I started talking about sports,
the level of fucking anger has really been ramped up on the,
uh,
on the emails to the point that I'm taking everything in a defensive way.
Like somebody actually sent me a hilarious email and I didn't even get it.
They said,
Bill,
once you started talking,
once you started defending bill O'Reilly last week on the podcast,
I shut,
I walked away from my recorder and I'm waiting for an apology and I was so like
read like five emails in a row of getting trashed that I wrote back.
Well,
why don't you go back and listen to what I said about it?
I didn't even get the fucking joke,
the obvious joke.
They got up and walked off the view.
So my apology to that person I just had written,
I'd read like fucking five in a row where I was getting trashed.
So I was kind of in that mindset.
So my fault.
Um,
look at that.
The comedian not getting a fucking joke.
All right,
plowing ahead here.
Um,
thanks.
Here's actually some from thanks y'all.
Bill,
what's up?
My name is,
uh,
I can't say your name.
I'm from Little Rock,
Arkansas.
I'm 23 years old.
Sort of a new listener to the podcast.
Been a longtime fan of yours.
Uh,
but just a few months ago I discovered that you have a weekly podcasts.
Um,
anyways,
it's,
uh,
it's all great,
Yada Yada.
Anyways,
let's get to the point.
I think it was,
uh,
maybe the second or third podcast of yours I had listened to and you were like
hung over,
I believe,
but you said something pretty God damn outstanding.
At least to me,
at least to me it was Jesus Christ.
Can you guys please use capital letters and periods?
You know,
I can't read out loud.
Um,
and he said it was,
this is the great advice you gave me.
He said it was the day when you discovered what a loser really is or it was the
definition of a loser.
Anyways,
you said the definition of a loser is someone who knows what they have to do,
but they always find some way to not do it.
And then he goes on to say,
man,
that shit was like so true to me because honestly,
I've been that guy for a while.
It's weird.
Anyways,
so it was around the same time that school was about to start up for the fall
semester.
So of course it's that time of year where my family is looming over me.
Like,
what the fuck?
When are you going to,
uh,
get your life together?
Anyways,
when you said that,
I was like,
Whoa,
okay,
so fuck it.
I got up and went to the University of Arkansas,
Little Rock,
found out what I needed to get done to get my ass back in class.
To make an already long story short,
it went out,
got my GED,
took the Goddamn Act test.
I don't even know what that is,
but he said,
which I failed miserably apparently.
So the school told me I had to take the compassed test to get in.
Took that thing,
had to go through all the turmoil of finding my six year old high school
transcript,
which had been transferred to a billion places by then.
Um,
I wanted to say,
fuck,
it's so bad during all of that crap,
but I kept repeating that shit through my head of what the definition of a loser
in any ways.
I'm halfway through my first semester as a freshman at the University of UAA l
are whatever that is.
And I have,
uh,
and I got a 98% of my midterm and I can honestly say,
if it wasn't for me listening to your podcast,
I'd still be ignoring that voice in my head.
Uh,
it will,
I'm sorry.
It's still ignoring voicemails from my bitch,
grandmother,
Jesus,
Dude.
Trying to pes pester me into going to school.
She just wants what's best for you.
Um,
so anyways,
I wanted to say thanks and all that type of shit and uh,
don't be scared to toward the south.
Me and my brother,
huge fucking fans and uh,
and he's about as Hank Williams as it gets.
Well that's good.
Look at that.
See other than pissing people off,
every once in a while I helped somebody else will.
Congratulations Dude.
Stick with that ship.
Wear a condom.
That's the other one.
Respect yourself.
Where a God damn condom,
uh,
key and keep that fucker on until you know you're with the person you want to
marry.
Then Merriam and be in a financial fucking position to bring somebody else into
the God damn world.
Have a game plan how you're going to marry him.
Have the condom on while you're having that conversation.
All right.
Then have a fucking kid says the guy who's never had a fucking kid.
What the fuck do I know?
All right,
let's get to some questions and then some youtube videos and then I'm done.
Here we go.
Uh,
question.
but,
but Buddha,
all right,
send some Monday morning podcast is rolling around.
I thought it'd be interesting if you rambled about this idea.
Maybe the question is more,
when do women deserve to enjoy sex?
Um,
um,
always.
Okay,
let's delve into this one recently.
It's their fucking sex life.
They can do whatever they want with it,
right?
I recently went to a mutually agreed upon dinner with a very motivated,
independent woman who expected me to pay for dinner.
What is a mutually agreed upon dinner?
Somebody had to ask somebody that dinner,
right?
I called bullshit and refused because as I told her,
I am not in the habit of paying for people's time,
especially not people I know to be manipulative and who absolutely don't have
sex before marriage.
All right?
To right off the bat,
if you don't pay for people's time,
why would you go on sort of,
not a date,
but sort of a date with somebody that you know,
manipulates people and who doesn't have sex before marriage?
Uh,
is this so you could have this argument with this person?
I mean,
you sound like an intelligent guy.
You know where the fuck this is going?
Uh,
whatever.
I'll read the rest of this,
but this is one of these things he'd got to get out of this Rut.
This does.
There's not plenty of good women out there the same way.
There's not plenty of good men out there.
You've got to find them,
but you can't dating the same person that's going to keep reinforcing,
uh,
you thoughts or else you're going to end up like make,
which I'm not right now because I finally found someone who was awesome but uh,
you know,
half the shit that I call women on or is the shit that I see on TV and residual
baggage that I have from dating the same fucking psycho from year,
year after year.
Ah,
Jesus Christ,
I'm really on my soapbox.
I'm just shut the fuck up and read the rest of us.
But more importantly I said what this woman failed to understand was how much
she lowered herself and is seen by saying I need a man to pay for my meals,
which is all the same time bullshit.
The whole idea of the dating dynamic is really warped.
What are you paying for if not sex you are paying for,
you are paying for sex.
What if you are paying for sex?
And I think women,
the woman forfeits her rights to have fun in bed.
Oh I see what you're saying.
Cause you're really just paying for a service at that point.
And you know what you are making points because there are women who will go out
with a guy on a Friday night because they're kind of broke and they're hungry.
You know,
you can't say that shit on TV because it's considered a misogynistic.
But you know,
if you're really fair about it,
women are just like guys that they get the,
if you let them get away with it,
they will.
And you sound like you're smart enough so you shouldn't be in this situation.
Um,
any continues and the whole,
whoever does the accent accent,
whoever does the ax asking pays for the meal bit is really getting tired because
the fact is women are pussies and they won't ask men out.
Yeah.
And there's also the other thing that a lot of guys get a little nervous if
women are being really forward and they're like,
Jesus Christ,
if she's fucking asking me out,
how many Cox is,
this bitch sucked.
Oh,
um,
but why are so many women in this post feminist world?
Why are so many women in this post feminist world?
Sorry,
guys who have equal equal earning power as men and who even have an overt
advantage in the marketplace these days.
Parentheses,
if they have a pretty face,
seem to insist on demeaning themselves to you.
You got a lot of issues here,
man.
Uh,
they have an overt advantage in the mark.
They're still making less,
aren't they?
At least that's what they're always fucking running their yaps about.
If they're good looking,
you know,
something that is a hell of a card to play.
If you're a hot chick,
how do you not get fucking hired?
You know what I mean?
Even if you are a fucking Bimbo,
you can go,
oh my God,
I love the carpet.
Can I have some money to be here?
I swear to God,
I'm always going to dress hot and pretend I like Ya.
Um,
why don't women so often refuse to step up to the plate and myth that they want
to fuck and put in their equal share
now that they have equal rights,
maybe there would be more satisfied couples in the world if women would learn to
do this.
Uh,
dude,
you sound like me.
Like 10 years ago.
It sure seems to me that women are getting away with murder these days.
They cling to old school.
The idea is about paying for them to live while making a better living than the
guy they're leeching off of and expected to be pleasured wildly in bed.
How does that add up?
You can see it in newer poor now.
Wow,
dude,
you really,
you're really,
you're really connecting some fucking dots here that,
where do you see this in porn?
He said more and more time is being spent actually pleasuring the woman,
Eh,
Jesus.
Really in all those fucking boot,
cocky facial dude.
I really,
out of all the examples you're going to say that,
that women are getting pleasured more important.
Uh,
if they are,
it's probably about fucking time.
You know,
how are they getting pleasured more?
They're,
they're not getting fucking bent over on a subway platform and getting Bang Gang
Bang.
My fucking 12 guys.
It's just one homeless dude doing it.
You know?
Come on dude.
Porn porn is horrific.
You know,
occasionally where to women when in porn.
I think those,
those,
uh,
those strip ones where they just do the strip tease,
that one,
I think they win because there's no guy in it.
They just sort of turn the camera on this sort of in control of the whole thing.
Yet you also got to ask yourself,
why are they doing that?
What the fuck happened to them as a kid,
dad,
uh,
you know,
eventually made them think that this is the way to make a living in the world.
You know,
like that like this is going to lead to happiness.
Like you can actually do this film yourself and actually go out and find a
decent husband does are a person's,
it's a fucking settled down with someday.
Like they're going to be able to look past the fact that you were finger blast
and yourself on the Goddamn Internet.
That really sort of limits the amount of guys that,
I don't know.
I really come from the school that most of those people were fucking abused as
kids.
I really do.
It doesn't stop me from watching it.
Um,
so anyways,
this is what I would say to you.
I know you're probably fucking mad at me because you wanted me to fucking vent
your frustrations,
but uh,
I'm trying to help you out here,
dude.
Why would you,
there's no fucking,
you know,
something that Goddamned Jersey shore,
right?
The fucking,
the Nice Guy,
Vinny.
Oh,
that dude,
right,
right.
It's not like a moron here.
He went out in,
uh,
he met some girl down there and the whole time I guess she was,
she's been playing the guy like she was supposed to meet him at eight calls up
at eight 15.
She says she's just getting ready.
And then when he's,
when he's out to dinner with her,
she said something to the effect of like,
so will you get an upset waiting for me?
Did you think I wasn't going to show up?
And it's like right there,
right there,
right there.
You check,
please.
It's over.
You just fucking walk away.
Why would you wait?
The people who manipulate our,
our are honestly some of the biggest pieces of shit on the fucking planet.
There's no way you want to hit your wagon to that.
Even for one fucking night and all it's gonna do
a male of females.
It's just going to make you hate the opposite sex more.
You're,
you're dating cunts,
you're going on date with cons,
male or female.
You this,
why would you,
if you don't want to pay for somebody else's time,
all right?
That's because your time is valuable.
Why would you waste your time going out on a date with someone that you knew was
manipulative word?
I can't say manipulative,
manipulative,
manipulative.
That kind of sound right?
That's like learning a new drum.
Ruderman right?
You know,
just go full speed.
You've got to go right,
left,
right,
left us.
Only makes sense to drummers.
Um,
so that,
that's my advice dude.
Cause I could really just sit here and do what the 9 million fucking rant on
women or I could actually maybe try to fucking help you avoid some of the
pitfalls that I,
that I went through that there's no fucking reason.
The second male or female.
The second you figure out that you're with someone who's a cunt or you get that
feeling that the person I'm with is a cont.
Uh,
pay attention to that feeling.
All right.
When someone shows you who they are,
believe them go to a bad and if they're a client,
walk away.
All right,
real quick,
because this podcast is really long.
Uh,
I only have one youtube video of the week,
but this is almost like youtube video,
the week slash daily show moment of Zen.
Um,
go to the [inaudible] podcast.com and check this video out.
It says,
uh,
this is actually,
I found it on break.com and it's called dot chick make same dumb face in every
pick.
It's Kinda going back to that duck face.
It's,
it's actually,
it starts off funny.
Then it starts to get boring because it's so long.
And then it becomes like,
I dunno,
it's like astounding the amount of pictures that this woman took with the exact
same stupid fucking look in her face.
All right,
underrated.
Overrated for this week.
And then I'm out a overrated La love for your fellow man.
I'm tired of being made to feel guilty because I don't care about people whose
lives are not any part of mine.
Mostly because no one does.
No.
See because no one does and you're a hypocrite if you say you do.
We aren't designed to care about everyone.
If we,
if we were,
then we would have survived.
If you think about it,
I don't know what that means.
Resources or,
oh,
he's explaining it.
Resources are limited.
There's no shame in self interest.
Take care of your own.
It's a noble and honest outlook.
All right.
Underrated contest where you win something that isn't actually a prize.
I opened my flavored water and it said I won something.
I answered the code and the site to see what I won and hear what it is and I
quote by one and I'm not going to say the name of the water because they pissed
me off by one of these fucking waters and get one free.
Is that a prize?
No,
I think that's a fucking coupon.
You're 100% right.
CanNot agree with you more sir or ma'am,
whoever wrote this,
um,
overrated Cialis disclaimer on the commercial.
Do not drink alcohol in excess with Cialis.
The fact that they said it means someone out there needs both boner pills and
excessive amounts of alcohol in order to manifest the ability.
That ability to fuck whoever they're with.
Might be time to try a paper bag maybe.
Um,
all right.
Underrated to blade razors.
Surf,
I already mentioned this on the podcast,
so God bless you for backing me up.
Is it so hard to perfect the design of a shaving razor?
Is it every year they come up with a new design and how shocking they added
another blade.
Stop this bullshit marketing nonsense.
I hope no one falls for this shit to blades is all you need to.
Blades was the greatest one ever.
One digged up.
Your phase two was the greatest and ever since they are three or more,
you can't get those whiskers under your fucking nose.
It's a pain in the goddamn ass and it's not any closer.
I don't give a shit how many blades they have.
You know,
it's really like an unfair fight.
Like how many guys do you have to have Holden the fucking whiskers arms behind
his back and you come up and fucking start working him over.
Two blades is enough.
One holds the whisker,
the other guy takes out his fucking knees.
All right.
Overrated.
Twitter.
A number of people are apparently disappointed to find out that celebrities have
normal lives in that they waste time and talk about stupid shit like everyone
else.
They must have thought they were riding around on the back of a Griffin hurling
lightening with a magic hammer all day,
underrated sleep,
sex.
This is where this person becomes creepy.
And obviously I feel this is a dude at this point.
Uh,
this is the ultimate passive aggressive move to when you can't get any,
just wait until they're falling asleep.
Not only will they not stop you,
but they will,
but they tend to be much less critical of your performance.
Remember earlier when I was talking about sociopath running the fucking world,
this guy said overrated.
Um,
love for your fellow man or whatever the fuck the initial one was.
I remember the hell is it over?
Yeah.
Love for your fellow man.
And now he's talking about how sleep sex,
which really seems like a form of rape,
sort of rape life,
sort of a light,
uh,
sexual assault.
Okay.
That,
that one's just creepy.
Surf Ed.
And with that,
I think I'm done reading underrated,
overrated to at this point.
I don't want to see what the next two one go.
The next,
the next two ones go the next to go.
Ah,
who gives a fuck?
Anyways,
that's a podcast for this week.
God bless all the police come down.
I'm doing a benefit in Saint Louis.
Support the cause.
I have all the information up on my website and um,
if not,
if you just want to see me because of that show,
I think I've just doing 1520 minutes.
But if you want to see the full on me,
come to the Saint Louis funny bone this Saturday night,
which is Saturday,
October 30th the night before Halloween.
Oh,
come on down and doing two shows at the funny bone.
Seven 30 and 10 o'clock.
I've got my brand new hour of material.
I'll have my brand new DVD.
I'll have a brand new fucking shirt on.
Everything's going to be brand new.
Come on down.
All right,
that's it.
God bless all of you.
Have a great [inaudible]
dad.
I don't take it down.
She's in [inaudible] case.
Shoot me.
She Cs and you dare to try.
I said,
if someone's read not,
don't shoot your little woman,
my daughter pass shot gun.
It just won't fire.